okay just testing if this is live uh if
everything is working properly uh quite
a lot quite a lot to set up and not not
all that much time
uh but yeah i will explain what is
happening in a little bit but yeah it
seems to be working as people are
joining jaren chako ammo box bot squad
uh ridam lakotia uh amman jane superior
ninja uh ron weasley gospel into zarsky
so uh hello everyone uh glad of you glad
that you were able to
join in
so
i'm gonna wait for a few more minutes
and then we can we can dive into it the
uh the official event is supposed to
start in some 17 minutes will it be at
that exact time i don't know
uh but uh hopefully it will or rather
it should be i think it will be
on time
uh all right
just have to keep checking everything
uh poster of posterosima in the uh hello
everyone again to those of you who are
only joining in now so uh basically what
is happening today is that uh judith
polgar is holding a simultaneous
exhibition she will be playing against
uh
well not 10 people but rather 10
communities she will be playing against
the 10 streamers and their communities
so whenever udit makes a move you will
see the move here on the board
and then you guys are welcome to
uh to discuss and uh suggest uh uh any
moves uh and then we are going to find
the one that we enjoy the most uh most
likely it will be an attacking move of
sort
and then we are going to play that uh so
uh it's not uh it's not like you did
playing against the ten of us then
streamers it's rather you just playing
against the ten entire communities
that's the that's the whole point of
this
yes and as says it well hello everyone
and welcome back to the lychee samuel by
eureka polgar
yes hopefully hopefully she will uh she
will play the evan's gambit
how to deal with cheating then uh well
so many people we will be suggesting in
the end i am the one who will be
deciding on the move that will we will
play so hopefully
uh we're gonna play the most interesting
one at all times uh no it's not rapid
there is no time control it is a
correspondence game and uh well as you
did makes her route uh we just have to
make the move um
before unit reaches our border that's
how kind of how it should be happening
uh we'll see how it's uh how it's played
out here because udit is not playing
against the actual people she's playing
against automated chessboards
we will be making our moves here and the
chess boards are connected to the
leeches a website and then once we make
the move here uh you
the the pieces will move by themselves
on the
on the square of chessboard
is it possible to show the the letters
on the board uh it is possible to show
the letters on the board i i don't know
why they are not visible here or
they should be but yeah here they're not
maybe they will appear after a first
move is made
not not sure
but yeah it should be
it should be possible to see this but
yeah even in the leeches interface there
are no
uh there are no uh square letters and
numbers maybe maybe they will appear
once the first movie is made i don't
know if this is a theme preference or or
anything like this
yes hashtag better better than beth
harmon
she will beat us so bad that's that's
what we are expecting yes
ah the games start the games are
starting at uh 2 p.m uh we're still
making sure that everything is uh fully
operational
and that everything is uh
going according to plan so for the
moment it is should be should be okay
yes meadow is waiting too i might have
to at some point take meadow for a walk
but we'll see i did take him for a long
walk right before the stream so he
should be okay but you never know
judith is the queen of chess without a
doubt yes that is that is correct sir
uh yeah and at some point during the
stream i might have to uh uh
take a call as they will be uh
sort of interfacing with us uh for the
for the actual show uh so don't don't be
weirded out by this if i suddenly pick
up a phone and and start talking to
people
no it's not a three-minute blitz it's a
correspondence game so no time limit you
are welcome to discuss the moves all you
want and to make this uh experience um
as uh well as pleasant as possible just
enjoy the games as you know discuss the
moves suggest the moves but don't use
any uh outside assistance as that's
gonna be
uh well that that's kind of
spoiling the fun
yes the games should start in 10 minutes
unless uh unless something happens will
i post the video of the analysis as
usual most certainly yes
uh i most certainly will uh so it's
basically you guys playing against uh
judith polgar uh let's make it a good
one so we have uh plenty to cover in the
analysis video
i i'm seeing you bolu thank you for
joining in yeah
hey my choir uh thank you for the uh for
for being here the first time
uh it's uh yeah don't use outside uh
assistance like nigel kamath
abhinav gupta hello man
uh who's the other communities uh well
there are quite a lot of them uh as
you'll see uh later on
uh
to to give you the the full uh the full
uh go around it's um
on rudolph uh
anna kremling pepe jennifer shahadi uh
the magnus chess academy reenigma
samarina myself and uh
uh those are the the ten communities
that ut will be playing
all right
i have here the uh
we'll see here
i can't show this uh uh properly live to
you but i will just check on the
official stream okay so it still hasn't
started
uh just uh to make sure if you did is
already uh making her rounds or if uh or
if we we will still have to wait
a little bit
but that's fine
i'm always uh more than happy to just
enjoy reading what you guys write in the
chat uh
sometimes i don't have all that much
time to do this so now that i have the
time it's it's always a pleasant
experience
uh if the quality of the video isn't uh
up to your standard maybe you just have
to increase the
the quality because it should be should
be fully operational
i mean the the the the internet quality
in croatia is not spectacular but it
should be enough for uh uh for for a
stream with a with a chessboard
d6 against anything uh
we'll we'll see it it will be up to you
guys
yeah some people are saying it's fine so
it's uh probably a matter of only
adjusting the
uh the quality setting
yes i will continue my daily uploads if
i can victor that that is the plan
you think she will play more of the
retty opening she might
alright it is very popular and it's very
flexible uh but i think she will open uh
with a different move on on every board
that's kind of how
uh how simults are are done
i i think it might be like uh two or
three knights to f3s maybe two c4s and
uh something like that it is eleven
boards
will the evans gambit be on the board if
she plays e4 against us i will of course
allow for the evidence gambit to appear
on the board
that is um that is a promise yes
we we all support you that is true
yes sama is also streaming uh
everyone is streaming this this will be
the one of the most covered events uh
of all times i imagine
a unit is strong against the sicilians
so don't play that yes everyone everyone
knows that but you did this uh very
strong against any uh
any sharp opening for that matter
uh where can you see you did live uh
i will put a link to the official stream
uh on
uh twitch channel in the description
below
uh so let me just uh put this uh in the
description
let me see this all right uh
oh but it uh it kind of already is i
don't know this is the the chess
connects us uh okay let's write official
stream
there we go
uh
yeah hungary expo
2020 okay it's 20 20 22 but still still
should work properly okay so you have
the link in the description below uh
where you can watch the the official
stream let me just check how how that is
going
uh still says the show will begin
shortly i imagine they're still working
uh
on a few
details
uh it's quite a lot to cover
what do i mean by 11 boards well udit is
uh in dubai she's on the uh on the
hungarian expo and she has uh 10 boards
or rather 11 boards i don't know 10
boards are
for online play and the 11th one is for
an occasional viewer if someone visits
the expo they can play some moves there
and we're going to be making our moves
here
via deletious interface and the chess
boards there the square of chessboards
are connected to the leeches interface
so when we make a move here the uh moves
will automatically be made on these
boards uh for for you to
uh to play against so unit is basically
playing against the 10 chess boards with
no opponents
in front of her as we are all here
in our homes very comfortable
how do you vote for moves well uh there
will not be an official uh sort of an
implemented voting system you can just
uh type moves in the chat and i will
discuss the moves with you and we can
make
well we'll always go for the one that
seems the most interesting the most
daring the most dangerous so
uh
all in all we just wanna we just wanna
have a fun game
at the their time format is
correspondence there is no time
basically we have to make a move before
unit uh reaches our board
manu madrunat uh thank you for the
contribution man i'm glad you glad you
enjoyed the content
yes i mean who who does not fear b4 that
is that is the real question
how do you offer a draw oh well
uh in real life you just offer it and on
leeches there's uh this uh
uh
one slash do which means offer a draw
yes there are many openings we can go
for
am i the most famous person from
creation not not by a long shot
ah nice to see you live i thought you
wrote nice to see you alive
yes ray enigma is playing as well
uh
no no no no draw offers we play it until
the the the bare naked kings
all right let me just check if if we
have any
any information on this nope still not
nothing
uh also if you guys have any questions
feel free to ask in the chat uh we have
uh we have some time until uh the the
sam all starts
yes yes samai is also playing we are
expecting great things from samai
will i ever do a collaboration with
hanging pawns uh i might i i don't know
i don't really do all that many
collaborations uh i'm i'm kind of a solo
writer here
is you did also streaming uh well she
will be playing so she will not be
streaming uh herself but it will all be
streamed on her twitch channel yes
which you are welcome to follow uh for
the moment i think it's a new channel it
has some 60 subscribers or they're
called followers on twitch
when will the podcast return uh when my
my baby girl grows up a little bit uh as
uh she is uh quite quite a handful at
the moment so not a lot of time for uh
other activities
why is med always sleeping uh well he's
very old and uh he usually
just ate
so he likes to have his uh his nap
yes i will cover this match that we play
against unit unless it will be an
absolute snoozefest in a video most
likely today or tomorrow and uh we might
cover some of the other uh games as well
we'll we'll see how it goes
how old is she uh if you are referring
to my daughter she is currently nine
months old
so
quite a quite a young one
do i still smoke no i i quit some
i think it's like five years ago now
something like five years
maybe six even i don't know
yeah i i i can see a lot of you are
writing that we should play the evans
gambit however we are playing with the
black pieces so if you did throws an e4
at us of course uh you guys are welcome
to suggest e5 and then we are uh gonna
try to go for the evidence but then we
are going to be playing against the
evans gambit do you guys really want
that
and yeah i i think if we face e4 that we
should go for the sicilian that's going
to be the uh the craziest game and uh as
you did is such a fierce attacking
player i think we're going to have uh
uh the the most enjoyable game for to
watch and even to cover later on
no no everyone is playing this is a unit
against community or rather a unit
against 10 communities so she's playing
against all the communities at once that
is that's the point
am i coming to india for the olympiad i
i would very much enjoy that but we'll
see
play the hyper dragon yeah hyper dragon
is one way to go about it
uh we'll we'll see
all right uh it seems that everything is
set
the show begins in a few minutes uh
so
let me just check this
all right
all right it seems that everything is
fully operational now
oh i'm not nervous i'm not the one
playing you guys are playing
you should be nervous
yeah when you that makes the first move
then you guys are welcome to suggest any
move and then we are going to see what
fits us best
uh if it's if it's a queen's gambit you
would like the queen's gambit to be
accepted all right
yes i i control one board that that is
correct
yes neither of those are all all very
good ideas uh on how to get destroyed
quickly by unit
but i imagine anything we play the the
outcome will be the same uh so we might
as well enjoy it the most
is it possible that we face uh 1b3 uh it
is possible uh i've i've done some work
on 1b3 for white and black so
we might be able to to survive a little
bit in the opening but like i said i i'm
not the one playing this i'm just uh
transferring the moves you guys are the
ones playing this
yeah yeah of course no engines that goes
without saying
yes as more people are joining more
people are asking are we going to play
the evans gambit that is impossible as
we are playing with the black pieces
what was the process of choosing who
controls those 10 boards uh well i think
the process was just you know celebrate
chess and that you did gets to play
against as many people as possible
uh so i imagine they invited streamers
who have large uh communities uh
and that's that's pretty much it i
believe
yeah later on of course we will make an
analysis uh
of the video and yes you are correct you
guys get to play you did today
no you cannot cheat even a little bit if
i even smell cheating i will play such a
silly move that uh
that you know it it will all be ruined
yeah but that's kind of not the point i
mean it's it's silly to even discuss
such things
who are the other ten players okay for
those of you who
uh still have not heard
uh let me just
mute you different okay uh for those of
you who still uh haven't heard so the
the other players are uh
ana rudolf
uh anna kramling pepe wink jennifer
shahadi uh the magnus chess academy
re-enigma uh samiraina myself and
ozdarva so those are the the 10
communities that unit will be facing
no stafford please all right
yes yes of course yuri pogba is playing
she's the one playing against the
against all the communities
all right let me just check what is what
is going on so the show will begin
shortly all right so this the show still
hasn't started which is perfect
whoops sorry about that
uh which is perfectly fine
uh as we have time for some extra
questions if you guys have any other
questions about the channel about chess
in general about you know
anything uh feel free to ask as we seems
that we do have some time
is this the good stuff yes i believe
this is as good as the stuff gets
against london system we play knight f6
c5 queen b6 that is uh that is true that
is uh one of my favorite ways to do it
although i've done some work on c6
instead of c5 and queen b6 and also just
the the standard way of facing the
london is also pretty cool so it's it's
okay
if you know how to treat your light
square bishop against the london then
you will be fine
yes not only can you suggest moves you
have to suggest moves that's how we will
be choosing the moves
how did i decide to start the channel
and quit partying i never started uh
i never quit partying and i did not
decide to start the channel it was uh
you know
and in a process of uh
of both just nicely blending and then uh
you know tending to the channel over
overtook partying
what is my proudest game in my chess
career well my chess career is a fairly
short one but i do have one game that i
am extremely proud of that i still
haven't shown on the channel
i'm waiting for the for the right moment
to to do so but you guys will enjoy it
it's actually my first game against a
feed a master
uh that i played i was um yeah i think i
only just got in my rating i was rated
1600 and it was uh well i really really
enjoyed that game
can i show the grid on the board uh yeah
someone already required uh or rather
inquired about this okay so we have a
move
and the move seems to be knight to c3
all right there you have it knight to c3
what do you guys what do you guys want
here
so this is uh this is absolute madness
we have knights to c3 and you guys can
go for whatever you want so i i suggest
we just keep it very principled and uh
well
yeah occupy the center however
how else would we play this so basically
you guys are between e5 and d5 let's go
e5 and then we'll see
all right
let me just check
all right so the show has started
but i i uh the second one will not be
made so quickly i think this is just the
test if it's uh if it's working
yeah yeah this is just a test if it's
working as uh the game has now been
abandoned so
false alarm
uh i would i did consider doing polls
but youtube does not have a poll option
for some reason during live streams
so we are we are sticking to suggestions
yeah she resigned already yeah
that's true
yes you guys you guys were simply too
strong
all right let me just check if
all right so still nothing uh
i think first now everyone will have to
introduce themselves
let me just check this this is gonna do
things like this it's your move
all right so there there you have it
that's from the official stream you can
also check out the official stream uh
just to know what's currently happening
uh
yeah knight c3 e5 and we win that's that
that's true
how can you see the other games uh
you can see the other games uh by
i actually have no idea there is a world
board that you that you can watch uh
that's a board where the entire world is
playing and everyone can make moves and
it gets voted on i've put a link to that
in the description below but uh you have
to
i think grab the games or the links that
are games from the other streamers
yes yes i will do an analysis on this
game and if you guys enjoy any other
games from the other streamers we will
also show that one
all right sorry just setting something
up for the
uh
for the actual uh
actual actual stream
uh no it it did not crash we were just
preparing everything i have to mute my
microphone uh on the other microphone
that i'm using so should be
uh should be operational now
all right
uh let's just see what's what's
happening on the actual show
all right so basically now unit will
have uh
you know an introduction she will uh
have a few words with with each of the
participants and then we are going to
start the games
although yeah i actually don't know why
this one was abandoned that's uh
actually really weird
uh so who is judit actually playing
against eureka is uh playing against all
the communities simultaneously so she's
playing against the 10 of us who are
transferring the moves from
our
communities to to the
boards that are making the moves by
themselves
how many push-ups can i do uh
not a lot not a lot i've the the most
i've done is 45.
once i i almost reached 46 but uh it it
did not
go all that well
yes anna rudolph is one of the players
all right everything seems to be
operational now
hope to see a queen sack yeah we we all
hope to see a queen sack
uh the
it's a shame that discord does not have
a stay on top um
stay on top feature
we should all have a beer if we win uh
that is that is definitely true we
should all have a beer even if we don't
win
uh you guys are welcome to
have to visit my hometown and there's uh
there's really awesome beer here uh we
we could definitely have a beer
uh how will we celebrate if we win oh
it's uh
all right
getting some challenges here but today
we are only playing against unit so not
accepting any challenges for the moment
uh some some are underage well obviously
the the offer is uh meant only for
people who are off age to consume beer
that is uh 18 or or 21 uh depending on
where you live
all right so getting uh getting some uh
some challenges but uh today is not
meant for challenges or who knows if we
finish really fast then we could
do some challenges we're probably gonna
even if we lose or you know if it ends
any other way uh we're gonna be
following the world board for for the
rest of the stream
hi it's persian new year
i did not know that
a new year eve
is my name anthony no
but it is a sort of a variation of the
name
the time control is infinite time or as
we like to call it correspondence
uh unit has all the time uh all the time
in the world so whenever she feels like
it she makes a move and then we we also
make a move
okay let me just quickly check how
everything is uh
all right so playing some promotional
videos now very nice very nice
maybe we can even show it now you guys
yeah
uh let's not let's not do that
i'm just gonna mute it
there we go
ah there but it's uh basically the the
commercial for the for the dubai expo
you guys probably already
have seen it during the world chess
championship between magnus and nipple
it's very very nicely done
the video i have not seen it in person
but the video is very nice
all right any other very important
questions
muted udit no no no we did not mute use
it we only muted the commercials
uh
neither really as we have uh we have a
really cool beer right in uh here in my
hometown uh the the crisis
uh that is that is the one that we like
to consume here
yes showing a promotional video can be a
nasty opening
uh okay as a lot of you guys are
requesting me to
turn on the coordinates i will
attempt to do so
uh
but i don't know where
peace destination board cord is ah okay
okay okay
let's do it like this
uh should be should be visible now do
you guys see the coordinates now
yeah no idea why this was turned off
yeah uh good of you good of you to
notice this this would be this would be
very annoying
yeah for those of you who don't know the
the board by heart
uh you should practice it it's very
important to notice but
[Music]
it would be it would be quite
challenging
yeah you probably just don't see them
they are very very very small here but
you can see right in the in the lower
left part there's the a b c d and then
on the right column there's the one two
three four five six all the way to eight
uh
no the game will not restart from this
position where it ended uh probably the
game will restart from an absolutely new
position
but
we're still waiting to see
okay so i think we will be getting
another challenge now
uh waiting for it but no
okay so it's taking a little bit longer
but uh
there is quite a lot of progress here
and it's you know it's uh
coordinating everything with so many
people
uh and uh you know definitely not easy
all right
all right so it is confirmed we will now
be receiving a new challenge
so when this is uh
when this is uh
uh
completed okay let's see is it no that's
not the one that's uh that's a
someone just sent that
okay let me just check something
okay still nothing here
all right
don't mind me just staring at the screen
i'm actually just uh
concentrating on something as we are
trying to coordinate this very very
impressive task
so yeah this is this is just me
concentrating nothing nothing uh wild
happening
yeah yeah like i said if uh if it will
be possible we will play the evan's
gambit with black uh but uh you know it
all depends on what uh europe plays
speaking of the study judith that view
that we just got for a moment with the
circle of chess
all right so
there we go it's uh about about to begin
so let me just check one more thing
okay
uh no i i have never been to india
unfortunately
it is it is definitely one of my one of
my plans
has already ever played against udit i
don't think so i i could be wrong but i
i really don't know
high speed turtle thanks for the
contribution man
uh no i don't think you win a prize if
you win uh it's more of a i mean you've
uh the community defeated unit so it's
uh
uh it's uh i mean a prize in itself what
more could you want
no this is not this is not the bone
cloud yeah
uh no okay when the when the game
actually starts we will
we will have the black pieces nowhere is
there
what a community isn't it just the world
uh well there is one board that's a
world board where anyone can make the
moves but uh here uh we will be playing
uh as a community against udit and then
uh she will also be playing against nine
other communities
can we win today it is very unlikely but
it is possible
okay let me just check this
real quickly
[Music]
yeah that is uh that is the biggest and
most relevant question we can only play
the evidence if unit opens with e4 and
everything else goes our way otherwise
uh not not likely to happen but we are
we are definitely going to try and play
the most impressive game uh whether
whether we win or lose uh that will be
definitely fun to analyze
yes the kings evans uh morphe variation
that is that is the one one that we are
hoping for we'll see we'll see how it
goes
uh yeah the chat is actually in slow
mode so one person can only write
something every 30 seconds or at least
it should be because i have turned on
slow chat
who is my favorite chess player that is
that is the secret
oh god that wasn't required but let's
see that
i can always do jp versus the word oh we
can always do um
all right so they they've started uh
getting people into the show so
we are we are on our way so after nine
people uh say hello myself included then
the games will start that's the that's
the plan and then everything will uh
will be going smoothly
so hopefully i don't miss the start but
until then yeah you guys are welcome to
ask
some questions like i said
hey morgan h
uh hoodie guys squad activated that's
right summon your inner hoodie guy and
let's let's do this and also a high
speed turtle thanks again for the
contribution
i could play the pterodactyl but it is
definitely up to you guys what we will
play
uh who is playing here for those of you
who are just joining in uh the entire
community is playing against unit polgar
so everyone is welcome to suggest the
move and i'm the one who ultimately
chooses which move is to be played so we
are probably gonna use the the
uh craziest looking ones and uh
uh definitely not some uh sane ideas
i should wear a hoodie for luck ah uh
it's uh it will be a violation of the
hoodie principle we only uh where the
hoodie when we don't know who our
opponent is
uh otherwise uh well uh the idea the the
past four years uh of me wearing hoodies
will have been in vain
yes the invited influencers and their
communities are playing against the
strongest female chess player
okay so maybe maybe you guys can hear
this this would be a good thing to hear
she will be located in the hungary
pavilion at the expo 2020 and the
influencers can control the chessboards
remotely from their locations want to be
part of it
follow the stream on your favorite
influencers twitch or youtube channel
and help them to pick the best move
can we beat the world's strongest female
chess player of all time if we join
forces one board thousands of players ud
will be in the hungary pavilion at the
expo 2020 and you can join the game
online
make your moves on the virtual chess
board then the computer will accumulate
the votes and after each move it will
make the most popular one on the
physical board how can you join register
on our website follow the stream and
play let's unite in an epic game
how to join yeah that is the link that
i've put in the description below so you
can guys you guys can just you can play
on this one uh but here you guys are
only allowed to suggest moves and i will
be the one who automatic uh who
ultimately picks the move but on that
link you you will be playing on the 11th
board where if you make a move that move
is counted as a vote and then the move
with the most votes will will be the one
that's played
i imagine that will be the hardest one
and the most precise one uh
but we'll we'll see it's hard to predict
such things
how much longer oh it should be should
be happening any moment now
yeah okay still still uh some
commercials
yeah if we get a chance of course b4
will be on the board that goes without
saying
ah so this is how this is how it's
happening so we are uh we are accepting
the challenges one by one
uh we are uh currently uh
oh we are last okay we are ninth and not
last so we do have some time before we
and then we exchange a few words with
udit and then we
make our move and then the game the
games continue uh where we will probably
have around two minutes to make our move
as i imagine unit will play the moves
very quickly uh and well we don't want
uh
uh torture unit for 10 hours uh usually
a simultaneous exhibition of this sort
lasts for some maybe four to five
minutes so
for the five hours so it will be
it will not be
a simple task uh you know
even like this
alright so
we have the second person i will not
share who it is but you guys of course
uh can can
easily find out if you just join the the
official
chat all right any other uh
super important questions in the chat
you guys might have before we start
yeah there is no time format it's a
correspondence game it's a
correspondence game we have infinite
time or rather until unit shows up at
our virtual board
chess brings people release it is being
uh it is being completed as we speak so
uh should be should be around the corner
b5b4
uh i i don't know i think we can expect
pretty pretty old-school openings from
units so
yeah is the result of the voting not
just the majority move for the world
board online
yes yes it is
what do i think of uh results if alireza
plays against udit uh well now if they
play now i imagine alireza wins but
already wins against anyone so
uh if it was a a classical game with
judit in her prime uh i would i i would
go for unit uh but i'd probably go for
unit
against anyone in her prime
can i repeat all the other communities
uh representatives uh of course uh by
all means so
uh the other community representatives
are uh ana rudolf ketitsalashvili
jennifer shahadi magnus chess academy
ray enigma samiraina myself and ozdarva
so world the board is just gonna be ut
versus engines i imagine i imagine it to
be so but who knows you know people
might just uh go there and make a move
for fun so
your guess is as good as mine not
everyone is of a devious mind
do i still flip a coin for thumbnails of
course it would be irresponsible to do a
thumbnails without flipping the coin
favorite unit polgar game uh i don't
know if i have a favorite one probably
one against uh some of the top players
that she was able to beat maybe the the
one against anand that we've shown or
the one against kasparov
uh
as it's really it's really a spectacular
feat of of defeating someone like that
i don't neem saga uh yeah er definitely
one of the sagas that we are
hoping to make
before before
before we stop making sagas all together
but uh yeah uh ninja saga would would be
would go a long way
uh but i'm still preparing my next big
saga which is not the autonyms of which
one uh but rather a fine continuation to
the morphe saga
so we'll
we'll see if we if we reach the names of
its saga
who is ray enigma no one knows who is
re-enigma that is a complete mystery
okay let me just check who is who is
speaking
okay
yeah uh anderson saga also would go
nicely uh hand in hand with the morphe
saga but we are uh currently uh doing
sagas on world champions and anderson uh
although he is definitely considered to
be the the one of the greatest players
in the world or maybe even the greatest
player in the world before that brief uh
you know morphe flash
uh but uh we simply don't have enough
time i i'd have to either start making
uh shorter sagas or
i don't know how i would uh
fit it all together
i don't know i don't think levy is
playing i don't know and i don't know
why why he is not playing probably has
something to do with the event being on
leeches i imagine
no i still have not bent forward and
apologized uh we were waiting for for me
to mess up something to do that
how long will the move voting last in
the community board i imagine two
minutes not not longer than that
no no she's still uh no no these are not
the actual moves these are not the
actual moves uh the game will restart
and we will be having the black pieces
as the one who holds the simultaneous
exhibition has the white pieces on all
boards
ah units beat the polo in 26 moves with
the king's gambit that's uh
a very interesting i'm positive i
have seen the game but i just can't
can't remember it
but i'm pretty sure i haven't shown it
on the channel so might be might be a
good one to show on the channel yeah
uh will i do a mini series on the fisher
versus posky rematch no but i was
planning on do a really
like a continuation of the fisher saga
only at 60 frames per second
better of mortal i'm pretty sure i've
shown petrov's immortal game i could be
wrong but
yeah we've we've completed the kappa
blanca saga it took us quite a while but
we did it
if we ever see a free piece from you
don't take it steinitz saga is a is a
fine idea and would be a great
continuation to the morphe saga
oof
yeah maybe maybe next year we upgrade to
240 frames per second
strongest player i've ever met uh well
that would be magnus carlsen
if i if i have to be very specific
it's been far too long since i've
mentioned my excellent subscribers that
can not be further from the truth i i
pretty much mention it every video
if i don't i am i am deeply sorry for
that
yes those are final fantasy vii figures
in the back figurines if you will
when will i start arjun eric saga well
he already got his brief saga we're not
uh
we're not going to do serious sagas on
someone who plays a few games
and he's far too young to be getting a
saga kasparov is has been a world
champion for for many many years and he
still did not get a saga
yeah 64 frames per second would be good
too yeah
okay let me just check what's what's
happening in the actual show
uh
more more ads yes more ads that's what
is happening all right
yeah okay so even though the the games
do kind of start at 2 p.m i imagine it
will be closer to 3 p.m when the games
actually start but who knows
yeah ivan saga also would be would be a
fine one
uh please change chess set for wooden i
i think everyone enjoys this one the
most
why are you live why why wouldn't i be
live this is a live
event will i put a visit from
it versus rapport from yesterday i don't
know uh if i will have the time i
imagine this stream will last for some
five to six hours and then we already
have the second day of the of the
charity cup so
if uh if it's a great game i still
haven't inspected it closely then i will
most likely cover it after the event uh
finishes
uh i have not shown petrov's immortal
all right i will definitely look into it
no i did not see soupy's game against
giovanni vescovi uh also uh
if you if you could send me an email
with the pgn
all right
yeah i imagine there's still uh quite a
little bit of time before we get started
so any any questions you guys might have
i am here to to answer them all
while i'm
while we're waiting for the games to
begin
how to send suggestions uh best way to
send the suggestion is uh via the
uh my email
that is uh
or or by comments just youtube comments
that's also fine
meadow is 15 uh he he celebrated his
15th birthday a few days ago
all-time strongest chess player uh in my
opinion
that is impossible to answer there is no
there is no one answer for that question
can you do a brief biography of udit and
no one can do a brief biography of you
did that would be impossible
what position do you play in league of
legends uh i i go for fill and
whatever needs to be filled i i just
feel it but uh mostly i get i get
support but uh i don't mind playing
support as uh alistar is my favorite
character
uh but that's only when i play and i
haven't played for
well
a few years really
the most underrated opening i don't
think there's such a thing as the most
underrated opening
uh but might be something like uh
i don't know
um
now i i i don't think in modern chess
there there are underrated openings
uh meru is behind us he's he's having a
nap
effing geller yes effing geller is quite
the legend
sama is using
a plugin to tally all the move
suggestions uh yeah that would be useful
but i i i have not prepared such a thing
and i don't think it would be possible
to implement it in such a short time
and also i think uh twitch has a a way
of uh
doing this i i just uh don't think
youtube has such uh
such a thing and i i don't want this i
think that's uh that's not a good idea
uh because i don't want uh the i move
with the most most uh
votes to be played as you know people
might be using too much outside
assistance and then
uh the most popular vote could be the
the one that we don't want to play so
i'm just going to look through through
the chat see your suggestions and then
make the move that i consider
to be
well plausible
yes we will have the black pieces
dutch defense probably is underrated
yeah okay you could say that but still i
mean even magnus plays it uh on on
occasion
so
i don't know if it's uh
if it's possible to say that it's
underrated
eminem is the greatest rapper alive well
that is that is definitely up for
discussion
did yuri ever play the evans gambit i
would be very surprised uh if she didn't
uh
i'm pretty sure she has
yeah like no question about it
all right still some
still some ads being played so
we're gonna have to wait a little bit
longer
it looks so boring here without action
this is what a chess game looks like you
have the position there's the board and
you just stare at it sometimes for 45
minutes or maybe even an hour with
nothing happening sometimes no one even
walks by
uh i've had games where i've been you
know just sitting staring at the board
for half an hour and nothing in the room
moved if someone uh you know if someone
did a video of that moment it would be
like a photo not a video
what unit likes to play uh i mean she's
uh one of the strongest player players
ever she plays whatever she wants and
she she is good at it
uh when was the channel started oh long
long time ago i think in
2007 and the first video was uploaded in
2007 but it wasn't the chess channel
back then
uh it only became a chess channel i
think at 2015 maybe 2016
uh so i had like all sorts of videos
here some 300 videos that i've made uh
invisible as it would be pretty weird if
i still had them on a chess channel
will we ever get a tall saga well
you you did get a mini tal saga
sort of uh
um
his uh
uh candidates the 1959 candidates
tournament of course the most important
candidates tournament ever uh and his
match against the botwinnik uh so
that uh the games there are incredible
to to enjoy
uh and you guys are welcome to check it
out i have a separate playlist for the
1959 candidates that was played in
belgrade and zagreb and also the
separate playlist for the 1860 uh world
championship match against votwinik uh
like really incredible games with
commentary from tal himself from between
from some other very strong players
uh the problem is those are old videos
and they're at only 30 frames per second
but
something that we have to live with
richard fredlund no i'm not playing
against unit all of you guys are playing
against udit
i'm just uh i'm just a vessel that
transfers the moves to the to the uh
square of board
yes those are all was fisher the most
intuitive chess player of all
time uh i wouldn't i would not say that
at all i mean uh it's a very
unlikely that before fischer anyone
studied chess as much as fisher so
that that wouldn't really be intuition
uh one would one would probably put
capablanca as the most intuitive player
of all times as he never studied chess
he never studied openings or or end
games when i say never i don't really
mean never
i just mean that he you know when when
there was something to find on the board
he found it
i never said that i was starting the
steinitz saga this is only one of the
one of the possibilities that i'm
starting the steinitz saga
favorite current indian young chess
player well i i would have to go with
pragernanda if uh if you guys consider
him a young player or do you mean like
really really young
uh
but i i guess uh prague would qualify
for that
yeah sultan khan was pretty intuitive
too and he had such a such a short chess
career that no one really ever had the
opportunity to prepare uh to play
against him but yeah definitely a
a a meteor uh like like tal himself
if he if he remained in chess who knows
what what sultan khan would could have
achieved
it's hard to say the most romantic
player of all time
there were some players that were a lot
a lot crazier than tal when it came to
romantic play nish medina of only being
one of them
uh but uh
yeah compared to comparating with dean
of tal's tales games were pretty
pretty you know correct
all right let me just check what is what
is happening with the
with the moves
all right so we have a a second guest in
the
in the studio
uh
yeah
it will take a bit a bit longer so
so on to questions yeah
i i i don't think they they meant it to
last this long it was supposed to be
like uh a quick introduction and then we
played the games but i imagine they
well either had a
a bit uh well a fair share of technical
difficulties or they just uh enjoyed
this uh to too much and then we're gonna
go into the games later uh but whichever
the case we will we will get to the
games no worries
what's my favorite movie
uh
i don't know if i have one like
i do like to re-watch some movies more
than others
but yeah i i i wouldn't say i have a
favorite one
yeah probably something like five hours
should last for for some some five hours
maybe even six
is ivan the best player for magnus's
style uh probably not you you are
probably referring to that 2016 doha
tournament where where uh
uh
vasil defeated magnus twice in one event
uh so well it is uh possible i wouldn't
say that maybe best the counter calls in
style
as for one carlson doesn't have a style
or so they say and
another one evancho is the best player
to counter anyone
so you could answer that many ways
i live in croatia and i also am
originally from croatia yeah
no i don't play the guitar i i did play
it some 20 years ago
uh is it 20 maybe maybe 18 years ago
yeah
did i hear the song about hall of fame
uh
yes i i'm pretty sure i know the one you
mean
no it it has begun uh you guys can also
check out the the original stream uh
it's on the youtube versus the world dot
hungry expo 2020.hu
but you have the link in the description
of this so you can uh check it out at
least at least just uh
see where we currently are with the uh
presentation of the players uh who will
be playing and uh when will be uh when
we will be starting
why fisher never played e5 against
spassky's uh e4
i imagine uh
i imagined
no i don't think he was afraid that he
could not prove his article about king's
gambit as i don't think spassky would
employ the the king's gambit in world
church championship match i think it's
just that it's what fisher usually plays
so
oh yeah okay you could say that fisher
played everything uh i don't know
probably something that he he decided
that would be best uh
to play against spassky maybe he decided
that spasky was more solid against
an e5 ee for e5 than than in a sicilian
or or in the aliens defense
what's the one game everybody should
know
oh there are there are many games
everyone should know
uh but uh
yeah i mean
paul morphy versus uh
versus uh
uh the duke and the count the legendary
queen to b8 game yeah that's the one
that everyone should know
uh and whenever you are you know
explaining chest to someone who might
not be in chess all that much but at
least he knows the moves that's the game
you want to show him to
really get his uh
interest and maybe get him to to play
chess or the
like the famous greco miniature like we
could even show it here
uh can we
okay i never really use leeches for uh
for analysis
yeah but like uh
uh
yeah like e4b6 uh d for
bishop to b7 and then white plays this
bishop to d3 move and black strikes with
f5 that's the
uh the famous graco miniature and once
uh well it seems like uh you you cannot
capture because the g2 pawn falls but
then you're just gonna capture
and allow black to capture this because
now you have queen to h5 check and now
after g6 we're gonna play pawn captures
and now of course it seems that you
cannot capture because you get
checkmated so here black plays knight to
f6 attacks the white queen and now we
just say okay we don't care pawn
captures here we open up a discovery uh
we deliver check to the black king the
queen has to be captured it is the only
move and then bishop to g6 is checkmate
so this is i think
one nice miniature that you can show
everyone and that everyone will be
really impressed and will be very very
interested in maybe starting to play
chess
so it's seven moves uh really any an
enjoyable one
uh but there are of course many others
to choose from this is uh
merely merely my opinion
uh and i also think that this is uh if
you if you guys ever
tried using the the chess chess master
software i think it's
maybe one of the first games that you
have there under miniatures
how to learn the coordinates uh of of
chess for beginners
uh we'll just uh say the moves as you
play them that's i think the easiest way
why don't i show my games anymore i i
don't have all that many of them i don't
play all that all that much nowadays
barely even have time for youtube
why do you always say a bishop instead
of bishop
or i don't know i like saying bishop
uh
probably
in proper english it would be
bishop
uh but
i don't know bishop sounds uh
sounds right to me
yeah i've already mentioned that my
favorite game is the one that i've
played against the fide master when i
pretty much just started playing chess i
read i read two books one from kappa
blanc and one from tal and i
uh
thought i i was i was very impressive
and then of course when i played i saw
that wasn't the case but it's still
one of the nicest
nicest games uh
i've played uh but i will show it uh
uh fairly fairly soon
uh so so i am saying bishop right i
don't know then why some people are
bothered by my pronunciation of bishop
what's this game ah this is the famous
greco miniature okay for those of you
who are just joining in we can show it
one more time so oops not that obviously
so white will grab the center and if
black goes for b6 then we grab the
center bishop to b7 bishop to d3 and
black tries to trick us he says all
right you cannot capture an f5 because
your g coupon is hanging but we say nope
that's not a problem at all you are
welcome to grab our g2 pawn black
captures and now we
end the game queen to h5 check this is
not over by by a long shot black can
still defend this however if black plays
g6 and after pawn captures knight f6
then the game is over we are happily
sacrificing our queen with pawn captures
here and now after the queen is captured
we just deliver this beautiful bishop to
g6 checkmate
so yeah a nice greco miniature
how did your life change after becoming
a dad well you
you
sleep
a lot less for one
and uh not a lot of not a lot of free
time that's uh
uh you know the downside the upside is
that uh well you have this uh
beautiful wonderful new creature around
that's uh you know that's
better than anything you've ever seen
basically
so it's uh it's it's a nice trade-off
when will the matches begin that is a
good question and i don't think there is
a an answer to this just yet
thank you i am i am trying my best to
pronounce indian names but all the other
names as well
all right let me just check where we're
at at the opening is the orangutan
that's one before i think all right so
still presenting the players
ah okay someone is sending me a photo
from the expo of youtube waiting for the
for the show
uh to begin we can we can even show this
one uh
so you guys are uh
uh are uh
well following everything uh ahmed atea
sent us this so thank you for that
let's just check it out uh so here it is
uh let's insert what is this oh no
that's we can't use this one uh we'll
just put it here so you guys can check
it out i mean you guys of course can
check it out just by
uh watching the the actual stream but
this is for those of you who maybe do
not have such an opportunity or maybe
are just too lazy so here is unit you
can see waiting
uh for the moves to be made
and then you can see uh there on the
board
it says anna rudolph on the first
boarding ket
that's really then
and so on so on
as
this is uh the order in which the
players are announced and we are i think
board number nine uh so once all the
players are uh introduced and we make
the first move then it will go a lot
more smoothly and you guys will be able
to suggest the moves so
uh
that's that's the idea basically behind
it
if any of you are near the expo or in
the expo and have some other photos
you'd like to share with us feel free to
just you know share with us and i will
gladly share it with the community
uh
all right
no no it's not it's not only one game
do i do i miss making chess videos
uh
wedding videos not not really i've made
uh plenty of them enough
enough for a lifetime
i've been to oh i i think i've been to
around 300 weddings as a wedding uh a
videographer
so that's uh quite a lot
still still a fan of elrond yes i'm
still a big fan of elrond that goes
without saying
yes she's going to play all of them at
the same time that is the basically that
is basically the definition of a
simultaneous exhibition you are
exhibiting your skills simultaneously
what's the one book every chess player
should have uh that's uh that's a good
one probably
uh something maybe about the end game
it's okay maybe something from
capoblanca would be would be great but i
think uh
um
the the end game manual
would be would be the way to go
yeah uh the varetsky's end game manual
definitely is if you had to choose one
book i would go go with that one of
course there are many many opinions on
this but i don't think uh
if you had to choose one a bit better
than that you you don't go yeah silman's
end game course okay would be the other
recommendation i'm i'm still
as i haven't uh started silence and game
course i have gone through the
dvoretsky's endgame manual i i cannot
vouch for for silman but
i know what people are saying about it
and yes they are saying that it is an
incredible resource
i do not have a favorite sith lord
how did i prepare for this match well i
made sure that everything is fully
operational and that you know my
internet connection is stable and well i
i'm not the one that will be playing you
guys are the the ones that will be
playing
all right so currently sama is being
introduced so we are
very close to i think we're actually
next
yeah i think
we might be next
and then
one more and then it's starting
uh
yeah meadow is 15. he's he's a really
old dude
all right i think it's uh very very
close to the to the beginning so uh
prepare yourselves uh as the games are
about to start
and then we we accept nothing but the
the greatest of moves
yeah yeah
how much time uh
we do before submitting the vote
uh the moves have to be played fairly
quickly so
yeah the board will be flipped if we are
black of course
no no you should suggest here uh in the
chat as uh uh
i have youtube chat here lychee's chat
here so it will be i mean you can
suggest anywhere you want but i i i
would prefer the suggestions that come
in the youtube chat
ah we are now featured all right
that is that is great
on some amazing incredible educational
content and we're going to be having him
take on judith on one of the boards
along with his community
all right having that said
and his favorite chess opening is the
evans gambit i saw samia's as the king's
gambit and uh
antonio's is the evans gambit so when we
have a gambit on the board greg at the
very start it basically means you
sacrifice a little bit of material
usually a pawn and you try to play for
the initiative you try to get the attack
going you try to develop your pieces
really quickly uh so very interesting to
see how these players are going to try
to get the initiative against one of
probably the most aggressive players of
all times
so that's gonna be fun we've got one
more influencer just one more
let's bring our final influencer up and
this i know has been a lost addition to
our team and a very cool one because
this is uh
a very well known streamer from andorra
orts darva and he once again
loves chess in fact fun fact anna
rudolph has been training with him a
little bit has been having some sessions
with him a lot of connection between
these people a lot of connection and he
all right so this is uh the last one
being introduced uh and then we are we
are off
yeah tanya not only interrupting other
commentators but other streamers
all right
like okay gregory we have to bring you
up to speed regarding chess you never
mentioned anything about lip reading
that was
it's not part of the briefing that you
gave me back in the day i don't know if
you guys can also hear this
i tried to make it uh
applause
this was a clutch moment and we
definitely need a lot of applause for
this uh for this to go anna let's start
at the beginning
what is happening inside your head right
now what is happening
within your community
tell us all about it just so happy to be
here i'm really nervous because i never
had to play against judith i was trying
to say why i think it was still sign
language that judith has been my role
model growing up in hungary she was she
was my greatest idol as a kid i had her
autograph i played against her in the
symbol i studied her games and then we
became teammates on the team on the
hungarian olympic team i'm actually
wearing the uniform today
[Music]
all right so uh they have a little bit
of uh introduction more and then i
believe we we will be ready to start uh
but yeah it's it's a long event it took
really a lot to set everything up so we
can just you know have the games and
that's it there also has to be some sort
of uh
uh you know introduction to it and uh
well what not
who according to you can we call a
european tal
that is uh that is a great question i
believe many people would
be qualified to be considered for this
criteria
but it's uh hard to say
i i heard that uh ogden sweden of
croatia in his younger days had a well a
style very very similar to tall
yeah i guess we could play a few a few
bullet games uh or maybe blitz until it
starts but i don't wanna mess it up uh
you know when when it actually starts
no no the simul hasn't started it uh
it started then we abandoned it just to
see if everything is working properly
yeah do both okay but the double is uh
dubois is on a whole other level uh
considering uh
yeah but yeah you could you could say uh
if i had to say who would be uh in the
top level
uh
maybe the
you know playing like tal and maybe
maybe
yeah
well it's hard to find a better pick
than do both rapport is definitely out
there although if you ask her up or he
says that he's not even trying to play
complicated chess he just says that he's
you know
trying to play a precise and accurate
chess
all right we have the
there we go we have been challenged
let's see now
against judith because as i said now we
are colleagues
and friends and and we've never had to
play against each other we are always on
the same side we always on the same team
as organizers as commentators as friends
so this is the first time since my
childhood that i'm playing against her
and i'm just glad that the tomatoes will
take over and i don't need to take this
responsibility of or having to play
against her because she's thank you
andrew dubani thank you very much
so what i'm gathering
from all of this and i just wanna show
some fancy things that we can do with
the show is that whatever
judith is about to sacrifice you're
gonna be watch out it's my move
panicking
right so that is gonna be the point
where
uh
where you know
bad things are bound to happen
yes
we are ready to panic we practiced that
too
awesome
very friendly supportive community just
panicking together but it's not it's
nice to show some uh emotional support
between each other when all of you guys
are panicking right
yeah and
one more question that i have in mind is
as you know during your game there is
going to be
a certain situation where you might want
to use that one token that you have
asking for help from your opponent
asking help from judith
what are your feelings about this option
how are you gonna use this and
what is the style of doing it like you
guys paying and then all of a sudden
let's let's basically turn the tables
judy tell us all about what you think
about this position what do you think
what is the what is the situation where
you would want to use that chance of
yours
i think certainly chess wise it would be
in a very complex position where we
would want to ask judith about her
upcoming plan and how she's planning to
destroy our king's side and going for
the checkmate but in terms of the call i
was also also just thinking i haven't
had time to catch up with judith in such
a long time i might just call him to say
hi
okay
well sounds a little bit luxurious but
then again
some tomatoes might not need that edge
yes at all we will figure it out we will
and anna before we let you go and get
back to the game i want to ask you that
what are you happy with the way the
opening's gone and the outcome of it
yes the french defense is obviously the
best opening in the world i'm not biased
or subjective here and i'm happy that we
got that on the board
all right well uh
um stay tuned about all of this but i
think we have word about our next star
anna thank you so much for joining us
and all the best
tomatoes
thank you thank you guys and have an
amazing time at the show this is such a
huge event and i i cannot wait this to
be part of a world record too
potentially so we are writing history
here all right
fracture limb best of luck see you later
see you guys bye that's heaven we're
gonna have anna back shortly as well we
got an update from her on different
positions we've got one more influencer
with us we've got getty joining us with
her community let's get an update on how
things are going there hello katie well
well well another nice setup love it
huge huge applause to her as well hello
[Music]
oh yeah not today this is our musket for
uh for the channel and it's actually a
chess theme it's a check it represents
pair of bishop the strength of the pair
of bishop don't ask me why it's just a
long story
so katie are you hoping to get a pair of
bishops in today's game
oh
we hope we have to survive we have to
survive as long as possible because guys
uh while um you were talking we had a
little bit uh
coming going on over here and we have a
bats between the uh influencers and the
bet is the chocolate so the one who
stays longer in the game wins the
chocolates oh wow we really want to stay
longer
so all the influencers are in on this
and the one who lasts the longest wins
the chocolate is that what it is uh so
far we are four but um yeah everyone's
okay
enjoy yes
you love chocolates 100 kitty i see your
position you've had a royal lopez are
you happy with the opening and the start
of it and how your community's handled
it so far
uh i i don't play this i don't play with
lovers i don't play because i play
sicilian but i have seen a lot of judy's
games in and so that was another option
for us for sure we don't want to be
checkmated on the king side and this is
the move my chat actually wrote it on
the side on this side you can see here
some options those are the options we
have
uh for the year for the chat and they
are voting and we are making the move
which uh which gets most of the votes oh
so we are doing it the democratic way
okay
i don't know what the guys still have to
control
because they want they want to play some
king moves so i'm not going to do it
okay so there is a limit to democracy
even on your channel like up to a
certain point if folks are suggesting
nice moves then let them uh have it but
then again you have to cross the line at
some point yeah no bond cloud here
either and i have to say that this
opening approach that they've had the
chocolate vet so far kenny seems to be
going well you're going to seems to be
going really well for you yes
i mean look at her she's super excited
yet
but you know you can never know when
judy is going to be all like checkmate
in three movies
judy is amazing person she is sweetest
person you can imagine but when it comes
to the chess board
it's a little different
it's a different vibe yeah yeah dude
it's quite brutal over the chest but now
kenny i remember we were all in dubai
kitty was there as well for the world
championship
and at that time we could have never
imagined this event coming together and
all of our celebrating chess and playing
from across the world you've gotten into
streaming you have this amazing uh
community of yours that you know often
interacts with chess and you play
different games in it
what does this mean to them to get this
opportunity to play against judith
i think all of us are very excited and i
asked my chat
just to to remind me where they are from
and we are from all over the world and
this is truly one time life opportunity
for all of us
uh because it's not easy to play against
judith and i also liked some some sort
of like seems he changed his mind
together in this and uh yeah they are
very excited all of us are very excited
for this opportunity
okay and i'm just gonna ask this
question to to everyone so katie i'm
really concerned about how you're gonna
handle that one
opportunity that you can have to ask
judith for for help how are you feeling
about this um i'm ready i'm ready guys
i'm ready
all right
with the heart shape and thingy okay
yeah it's a little over hard here just
so tutu to be nice but we have this card
and we're honestly going to
uh use this opportunity
you're bribing judith with the heart is
this what's happening here that would
have been my
question
katie we are about to say goodbye to you
hope for the very best and we hope to
have you back with us really soon all
the best to you katie for the game it's
getting exciting and we'll see you soon
thank you thank you
coming up next we have a connection to
anna kremling anna is that right are you
with us right now
there she is hello there chad has been
going crazy about you demanding your
presence so
there
we delivered oh no that's awesome how
are you doing so far what's it like i'm
doing
i'm doing as good as you can when you're
playing against judith you know we're
just in move number three right now and
we're just trying to survive but so far
we've survived for three moves so that
is good can you give us a summary about
what's going on so far
well there is uh rosalina on the board i
believe i think that is what we're going
to be seeing so i'm happy that chat
decided to play a sicilian i was afraid
that we would i would have to play any
other opening because i've only played
the sicilian throughout my life so i'm
really happy that chat decided to be
kind to me and choose the sicilian um so
so so far i feel good about this
wow it's really important to feel
confident and good when you're playing
against someone like judith you've got
to like your position anna are you in on
the
on the streamers bet of who's going to
last the longest against judith
yes yes i mean as soon as i as soon as i
heard anna and samaya talk about it i
was listening in me and chat were
listening into that conversation and
then also i heard that kenny jumped and
i was like if ted is jumping in we have
to jump in yeah the challenge is
accepted though but it's just not our
turn yet so we once it
gets to our board we will play a few
moves and then
we will we will probably have a few
words with unit and then
uh we will
dive into the game
you're up against
the most attacking player of all time so
are you gonna go all out in this game
are you going to pick the options which
are super aggressive or will you try to
play a little safe against that
you see that's a dilemma that's going on
in my head right because for i mean in
one part i really want to play really
tactically because that's what i do but
at the same time i mean i'm playing
against
the queen of playing tactically in this
world so it's
it's kind of hard
this is exactly what i've been expecting
like
judith's presence is putting a lot of
pressure on you guys right it's one
thing to do your
your own play style but when you are
facing with one of the greats i'm pretty
sure it's taking a toll on you
yeah i know exactly exactly so i mean
i'm hoping that we can play tactically i
think that's the way i'm going to go um
because i mean you you have to do what
you're best at so i think we're going to
be we're going to be doing that and i
have a few things with me i have you
know i have a couple things i saw like
kenny was bringing some things i also
have a few things that bring me luck in
this channel so i have them around me
just to to really have that luck during
this game so i hope they work yeah try
to put them in the front of the camera
so we can see them
all right
little octopus this is one of those that
you know if you're in a happy mood then
you have this but then if you're in a
sad mood then you can do this
so are you expecting that turn is going
to happen once or twice during this game
right so you you might have a chance to
actually out
okay articulate what you guys are going
through so which one are you guys in
right now you guys still happy
we're still here but i mean in 10 moves
um you know i might call for a lifeline
or something and i'll be like this
you know uh the best thing to to get
yourself prepared with that toe is to
when judith's all right it's my move
judy's gonna be all over the place right
yeah when she says watch out is when you
wanna start calling in that lifeline
anna all the best to you for the game
and we'll catch up with you really soon
and find out how the progress is going
so far and hope you get that chocolate
we are letting you go
but just because pepe is ready to join
in on for our next interesting all right
good luck thank you meanwhile cheerio
meanwhile just one quick
comment based on the chat so as you can
see many of the players have already
started their game with judy what we are
doing is basically building up the
momentum
to start the 11th worldwide table you
can still join in on the fun so as you
can see this is a coordinated thing we
haven't started that game not because of
any technical difficulties but because
this is the outline the agenda of our
show the other streamers are already
doing their bloody battle against julian
we are building up the momentum for the
word table and not all the other tables
really and i think you can go and join
on any streamer
you can play anywhere and of course as
the global board the world board which
is going to start soon go to
chessconnexus.com and that's where
you'll find all the info to join the the
world table we do have a guest with us
one of the other influencers is joining
us so let's bring pepe cuenca on board
hello pepe
that is not hey guys how are you doing
hello
the man himself
yeah how are you guys so far how's it
going pepe are you interested in your
position i'm enjoying so much you know
our community here in chesterfield
spanish they're so excited already
suggesting moves openings and stuff like
that so we are really happy
you know pepe i remember at the match in
dubai in november when we were all there
the spanish pavilion was such a big part
of the of celebration of chess and i i
feel that in spain and online the
spanish community is always so thrilled
and excited about a game and a chance to
play against any of the top guys
or in this case a woman
yeah yeah they're extremely exciting in
spain there there are so many chess fans
you know and
you can see that whenever there's a
super tournament in spain there is so
much crowded you cannot imagine so of
course today there is a this is a one
lifetime opportunity to play against
judith pogart and we know and uh it's uh
it's extremely extremely great yeah you
know we've been asking the different
different influencers how they're
approaching the game so because it's
against the communities right it's a
it's against the players and all your
followers so how are you gonna do that
is it gonna be a mix do you have a poll
system going on take us through you're
gonna pull that off
well actually our community is going to
play us you say like we're going to
propose some moves and they're going to
vote actually and they're already being
extremely aggressive because they decide
to go for the neither variation of the
sicilians so they're going all in
against you dude
but i don't i don't know if this is a
good idea because you did is such an
expert in in this opening so we're going
to suffer a lot for sure well and all in
against judith with the night of opening
i think this one's going to be a fiery
match now uh according for popular by
popular demand pepe uh you know what the
chat wants you know what the audience
wants
can we have it one time
sure yeah that's uh that's it right so
we're gonna enjoy a lot and uh let's see
what happens
no we can't let you go without the world
famous ratatata ah you want me to say it
of course yeah yeah let's go for it in
three two one
all right all right
all right pepe thank you so much and
we'll be uh we'll be keeping an eye out
on your board and discussing it soon and
we'll have you back with us definitely
all right guys thank you but in the
meantime
we are about to jump in on another hype
chain this time we have a chance to talk
to jennifer right
we've got jen joining us and she her
board is very special it's an all girls
all women's board it is the year of
women in chess and jennifer does a lot
of work for promoting and encouraging
girls to take up sports so i think this
is
to take up chess
and she's done brilliant work around it
so i think this board is so exciting
and we also know that for judith this is
an important cause and i think we've got
we've got jen with us jen can you hear
us
yeah
hey
oh there she is hey there
hello
hi
hi jen you seem really relaxed and laid
back and chill for someone who's playing
against judith right now yeah something
is something is suspicious
ah jennifer is there what
is here
sorry guys hello
yeah there are still a few people in the
introduction and only then will we will
we get there
uh
but yeah i imagine we will also get our
chance to talk a little bit uh so if you
guys want anything special said and now
is the time
uh and then i can transfer it over to
the live show
okay so we do have a move we have e4 on
the board from unit uh she made a move
now we what do we play against e4 guys
this is it
you guys are you guys are welcome to
suggest anything in the chat and then i
will uh of course uh
decide
all right everyone writing moves so i
can see
so okay pretty much everyone is
suggesting the sicilian defense so i
guess we go with c5 okay let's uh let's
get destroyed properly all right
all right so c5 it is all right we're
gonna go with c5
all right
as sharp as possible so only extremely
sharp moves will even be considered
all right
we'll see how how long it takes for the
move to be made
sicilian in today's times yeah
or uh for uh for a symbol definitely
no it would be too scary to play against
the evans gambit so and
too many of you guys suggested c5 so
we're going with c5
so i imagine it will take around two
minutes for you to make her
to make her
round
a sicilian in this economy yeah
she plays against all of the players at
once so she plays against the 10 of us
transferring the moves of the community
how do you say this is a completely new
game in creation
one would rarely say that
but it would be something like uh over
novapartia or igrad depends on what you
use for a chess game
to be named an honorary grandmaster when
they get to you unfortunately they are
not the ones who decide on such things
only fide can grant that
but i think we've already discussed that
maybe it's best if uh if uh we leave
rasheed where where he is as this way
uh
you know like i said so many grand
masters who are not considered legends
and he is a legend who who is not a
grandmaster so i think he he would
appreciate that
in his own words like he said after
uh his uh well game against pologovsky
kologevsky defeated him like eleven to
one
and uh pologreski said that he would
trade all of his victories for that one
game that uh medina won against him so i
think it's maybe it's even though
it kind of seems right for him to have a
grandmaster's title but maybe it's even
more special this way
all right so who is next
are you with us
daniel from the magnus carlson academy
that
okay let me just check
yeah i thought maybe there will be
why did we play the sicilian uh i i
thought it would be the the most fun for
everyone as it's uh very you know
tactically present
i thought maybe there would be a video
footage of just youtube actually walking
around the boards that we could also
implement here but doesn't seem to be
the case
how are the moves picked
well you guys suggest the moves write
them in the chat and then we play
something
uh if i like a move and if it's uh
something that
could be considered aggressive then
probably what we are going to play
will i revisit the game of the century i
don't think so i think we've uh done all
we could there i could uh remake it in
60 frames per second but
it just doesn't seem to be all that all
that necessary
units video is available in zoom oh
i could be yeah i could be but i have
the zoom on my on my phone
i was afraid to to
enter the zoom with my
uh with my computer as to not uh
use the same internet for for my stream
and for this uh thought maybe it would
be too big of a strain on it
uh but yeah i will check if this is uh
the case
oh yeah yeah okay you it's uh you this
video is on
yeah yeah that's uh
that is true
all right so she seems to be
going fairly quickly about it okay she's
reaching our board
all right
there we go
yeah she'll be
okay one more board and then she arrives
at our board
why is everyone playing the sicilian i
think it's because uh i mean it's the
unit unit plays uh e4 against us uh well
i mean what are we going to play
yes yes everyone here in the chat is
playing against you that that is the
that's that's true
all right so the only question is if she
goes for the open sicilian do we want to
play uh really really open or really
fast or even even faster than that so
that's that's the only question but you
guys will decide on this
all right so we are on the next on the
next player
who is the next player power level
because of their own stream and then we
have a chance to put them into a
situation where these guys are meeting
with someone online who they truly
admire i just love the dynamics
yeah i think it's uh it's really a very
interesting position for all of them and
i see i see vijay and chad saying looks
like everyone is playing the sicilian
i've got my eyes out on the game and
maybe while our next guest joins us we
could get to the chess action because
we're having a lot of openings all
across the boards the first few moves
have been played we know some of the
streamers they've mentioned what their
favorite openings are it's going to be
interesting to see if they manage to get
their communities and the telepathy
going uh and to achieve the position
that they want but before
all right so re-enigma is next and then
we'll see
rami thank you rami
yeah ah you you guys want the
accelerated dragon i think unit would be
extremely happy if we played that
against her so maybe we should go for
that
but you guys will we'll decide on that
okay let me just uh see it seems odd
that uh
she still didn't uh
play
a move
yeah maybe our move just wasn't
transferred to the board i will see it's
a funky business all this stuff with the
with the actual boards okay she's
going okay she's next to our board
is she gonna make the move
all right she's reaching out for for for
a piece could be a knight i don't know
could be a knight
uh seems that she played something but
we'll see we'll see if something moves
then she played it if not
yeah could be a king
but no
yeah it's a
strange to say the least because she
already made three rounds and she was
next to our board but the move is not
being made here so maybe there is
something
uh
strange happening here
it's hard to say
uh we'll see
once uh once we get uh you know everyone
uh
once everyone says hi in their official
stream then we can
uh turn that off and uh pay attention to
the games but for the moment no we are
not getting the moves in
yeah it's taking a bit longer to set
everything up but
no i don't think it's a glitch in the
connection
definitely
yes you should just push pawns against
the dragon some uh i i remember bobby
fisher saying that
is it too late for karo khan
uh well sort of sort of yes
yeah for those of you requiring
inquiring about the ratings
this is due to the correspondence format
being used so
no i don't think uh
refreshing it would help
not at all
leeches does not lag so
i don't think it has anything to do with
that
yeah luckily we cannot use a losing time
as there is no time limit here we have
infinite time
yeah queen to a5 obviously we start with
that yeah
yeah famous last words leeches does it
does not lag
vision
wow is that a little bit of an age dig
there say a long story greg i'll tell
you at some point but i have to ask you
you know you you are originally a
stand-up comedian by the way samuel is a
stand-up comedian
and then you went on to streaming during
the pandemic and then you know you have
done so much for indian chess and now
here you've given your community an
opportunity to play against judah it's
been such a crazy journey for you i mean
does it even feel real sometimes
you know you mention a stand-up but
honestly now i've been a streamer for
longer than i've been a comedian
so stand-up comedians become chess
players and streamers chess players
become poker players
crossovers happening yeah yeah i can see
a pattern over here
i know that secretly you're a major
judith fan
yeah big one no secret about it yeah no
secret about it anymore and you had her
a couple of days ago for a training
session do you think uh that's helped
you or prepared you for today's match
it has definitely made me much
comfortable and less nervous and she has
a phenomenal personality she's very
funny and she's very very charismatic so
i'm a big fan of course the chess is
brilliant but even as a you know i learn
a lot not only from a chess but also
from a personality and i'm so glad that
she gave me the opportunity to come and
play against her in this amazing simon
so it's nothing but an honor here and uh
thank you guys man i mean i'm really
excited
we are so excited to have you and you're
known as the blunder master now you do
know that if against judith you have a
you make a blunder that's it's probably
the only blunder you've ever been
oh yeah but the good part is that entire
community i can blame now after that
i am really good at putting the blame on
other people comedians are great
manipulators
hey does that come from is that why you
call yourself the supreme leader
yeah i'm the supreme leader of my army
today but the entire army is heading to
a blender i'm like i have a see my goal
is not to win against jerusalem i'm sure
i will not be able to do that my goal is
to win against all these streamers for a
chocolate challenge that we have today
and who will survive the longest and
that is what i am trying to do here you
think your community's got this one
yeah we have 10 000 people more people
we have better better decisions i guess
so really counter that that's
interesting but you know i have to ask
you how are you making these decisions
because you've got so many people with
you right now playing against judith so
how are you handling that
so we have a nice poll made here by uh
one of our community members itself so
now whatever the move chat is saying in
our chat we have like a like a graph
coming in our live stream so it will
tell you like right now entire chat is
insisting we play king d7 why are you
saying kingdom 7 chad
we're not playing
our life is unfair
oh that's an inside joke that's very
funny
oh chestnuts are becoming funny man what
do we do now yeah there's no need for
any stand up anymore uh but sometimes
there's always there's always
i agree unfortunately
is waiting for us so we're gonna have to
let you go right now and make sure to
listen to the right uh members of your
magnificent community and you know
let's check the next interview thank you
so much
see you guys bye bye bye
wow this is a really fun community as
well you know they're just it's just
janta for launch are going to be
interesting to see whether they get that
move king d7 i know they're trolling
somewhere with that and we've got our
next influencer with us it's dharma
welcome such a pleasure to have you on
our show how's it going so far uh cheers
uh i think this waiting is making things
a little bit worse on the nerves i come
from a slightly different background
than most of the other influencers so
there's quite a lot at stake i feel but
i'm very excited i'm very happy to be
here we're so happy to have you as well
now the one thing about you and your
streaming is it's so much about fun and
having a good time and you know it just
feels uh like a bit of a celebration how
did chess happen to you as darva because
you were a bit of a chess enthusiast how
did that come about
uh to me chess was something that i
learned um when i was very little but i
never really had any friends or teachers
or mentors to help me develop it so it
was just mostly forgotten for me until i
was in college and my lectures were so
boring that i needed to do something
okay we are next on the show and then
after that i think uh we continue with
the games
uh
although unit is making the moves it's
just that the moves are not appearing on
our board so
maybe she's waiting uh
for for us to get a chance to get into
the show and then we continue the game
could be that
uh
other than that i have no idea but we'll
see it we'll we'll find everything out
opportunity to play against youtube and
the other one wants to listen to the
people that asked me to play bomb cloud
uh
luckily the the wiser wolf is winning so
far and i'm gonna do my best
that is such a nice way to approach this
i love how all the different channels
and how the different communities and
their leaders are taking this so far
and i have i have an eye out on your
board uh
and i have to say that are you in on
that community challenge the influencer
challenge of winning
no no i understand that i am more of a
baseline my game might be interesting to
look at compared to the others because i
am an amateur player now obviously you
did is a very strong player but some of
these influencers are either
very big time chess commentators
analysts or strong players themselves i
am nothing like that so when you look at
my board you're going to see a lot more
what it would be like for a normal
person that just knows a little bit of
chess to play against someone as strong
as you did pogar so we asked this
question
exciting we asked this question at other
tables but i think in your case it's
even more important i call it the
frenemy moment the frenemy situation you
know that one at one point during the
game but only at that one point you have
a chance to ask for judith's help
now since you are so humble about the
way you approach this whole thing how
you gonna handle that one situation when
it's gonna be the time when you'll be
like okay
this time
i'm gonna use that frenemy moment and
ask for her help
um well i'm pretty sure i'm gonna see
struggles in this game that i also have
seen before like
all right so we have the second move on
the board uh
we can go for it knight to f3 so now you
guys get to choose do we go what do we
go for
what kind of sicilian you want this to
be
and after this i think we will have a
short chat with you and then uh
i think we we continue just with the
games
uh just have to make sure not not to
miss this one
all right so what do you guys want you
want e6 d6 knight to c6 so it will you
guys either want uh either one tonight
or for uh
or a dragon there are some other nice
ideas here
all right so mostly what am i seeing
mostly mostly
ha
it's uh
it's a very very interesting but okay
you guys are very persistent in it i
guess it is it is knight to c6 all right
that's what we're going for
all right yes night move because they
are tricky bastards that's
that's what i find most challenging is
is the fact that it sometimes really
does feel like some people are
on completely different levels and it's
really difficult not to compare yourself
to them in a way that that is difficult
and i think that ties back to what um
judy was talking about earlier
in the previous interview as the ancient
scene
easy to learn hard to master it's
impossible to be judith right
thank you so much as darva for joining
us and it's so nice to hear how much you
just enjoy playing the game and still
want to get better at it and i i cannot
disappoint anna she's coached me a
little bit i i want to do this and if
i'm if i'm if i'm going to lose to do it
in the most graceful way possible and
and enjoy it and learn as much as i can
all right that's that's what he finds
out thank you for joining in it's time
for you to get back onto your board oh
god i need to do that all the time
cheers
wow so that was amazing that was our
roundup of all the influencers and how
they're feeling about the events so far
yes greg absolutely and some of you
might have joined in on the fun a little
bit later so i think it's important to
bring you guys up to speed this is julie
wears is the word and in these last
couple of minutes we had a chance to
catch up with all the influencers and
how their communities doing in the
opening
the 11th and from a certain perspective
the most important board will start in a
few minutes because we still have a few
things to show to you
like the games themselves i think it's
time to get to the chess action we've
had a little chat with all the
influencers how they're feeling how
they're going to be deciding on the
moves and their strategy the moment that
they'll ask judith when they need her
help let's take a look at the actual
action that's going on on the board and
which influencer is going to win that
chocolate
all right so it seems that we are still
not on
uh so i guess we are just continuing
with this all right so d4 has been
played
i imagine we take c captures and d4
captures captures uh there's no other
way to
talk about this as everyone is agreeing
to this
uh
all right
uh c captures on d4
yeah i don't know they uh they they said
that uh i should i should get ready for
the
uh for the introduction but uh i guess
they are
probably going to insert it somewhere
else not really sure
yeah we'll get back to you
all right so what what do we play here
e5 next okay
uh i imagine she will recapture yes with
with the knight and what do we play
there
uh i i don't think we can even expect a
move other than the knight captures on
on d4 but it could be could be some
bishop to see for c3 could be it could
be anything
now of course why why would we play
something solid we play something
aggressive and then whatever happens
happens
pre-move f6 yeah
knight f6 next if white captures oh you
want it to be uh all right
you guys want the dragon or no dragon
okay you guys you guys decide
you guys decide what uh what you want
this to be
once fury captures
okay so most most most players have
already played quite a few moves i don't
know why uh our board is uh so slow but
yeah you did captures with knight
captures on d4 what do you guys want
what do you guys want
ah
you don't want the dragon wow everyone
is uh
either riding dragon or no dragon so
what move do you want
something boring something solid
something special
i don't know you guys suggest the move
and i'm gonna i'm gonna decide on it
no dragon riding no dragon is not a move
[Laughter]
all right i'm seeing a lot of uh i'm
seeing a lot of uh okay i'm seeing a lot
of e5s so you guys uh
oh that's super complicated okay
that's super complicated i'm very
interested in how you guys will play
this but yeah okay we do have some g6
all right e5 okay e5 uh
it's hard to decide hard to decide i can
see that you guys either want
uh you you want to play play the dragon
but also not so much
yeah that that would be a
that wouldn't be maybe the greatest of
of the variations
okay so you guys are are all serious
about this you wanted the modern okay
e5 let's go
if you guys want this we play this
e5 she resigned last time we played e5
okay
let's see this will be this will be very
interesting
yeah okay it doesn't necessarily mean
that i'm going to choose
whichever move is uh
mostly shown in the chat but i will i
will go for the more interesting choices
yes d6 will be weak but that's kind of
that's kind of what uh what you want if
you play the sicilian we we will
try our best to execute the d5 at some
point
yes pre-move king e7
uh it's uh well it's uh i i would not
call modern to be weak
we've seen it quite a lot in some very
top tier competition
yes yes we will of course make a video
about this game of course we will
it will be the the grandest of videos
because uh
well the player with the black pieces
will be all of you
yes danger is our middle name that is
that is well said
dolph i saw their opening it looks like
it could be dangerous so that one looks
like a bit of a ball that we'll check on
really soon which could turn
a bit dangerous for the community but
we'll come back to it and let's get an
update on the anarch crumbling board
yeah i don't know if they skipped the
introduction or they just moved it uh to
be used later on
uh but it is it is it is a little bit
weird yeah
why is the community board still
inactive i have no idea uh let me just
check
oh yeah the community board is still
inactive
uh but
okay we'll see
maybe e5 was not as popular uh while
while you did was still an active player
so who knows what she will play against
this line but i mean she she did follow
the uh
every
active event in the world chess
championship live while commenting on it
so i think she will uh know this
uh very nicely
ah the community board starts after the
influencers finish okay
i did not know that
oh that's a that's a that's a
[Music]
well layout plan how to get a draw in
seven moves from this position i i like
it although we
we don't want this we want uh we want
many chances we want her to get
attacking chances and we would like
ourselves to get attacking chances
but we'll see
uh i don't i don't
thing that we're gonna see capturing the
knight yeah i i i don't think that's
gonna happen
yeah of course
she will go knight b5 then we're gonna
go d6 and so on
yeah we are already crushing i i think
we totally confused her with our opening
choice after after three moves yeah
yeah that's true uh how how are we how
are we stopping uh b4 uh for the moment
we are guarding it with our knight and
the bishop so no worries about b4 i know
you guys are always worried about that
move
yes the most attacking move is always
queen h4 although
here i don't see how we would benefit
from from such a move
all right unit makes a nice move here
uh we'll see when they will when they
will be discussing our board i'm gonna
turn on the audio so you guys hear what
they think about about your position
could be
a very interesting
oh i i think she is
very much aware of it
is there anything left to be done yes
that is uh that is a good question
no i don't think it will go for 10 hours
i think uh once the
uh you know uh the the introduction in
the beginnings are made and after a few
more moves are made and i think the
the symbol will continue fairly quickly
panda panda i know you subbed after uh
short i don't know shortly but i know
i've seen you a lot uh quite a lot but
it's been a while since i've made those
top 10 videos
probably like six years or five years
tell you about meadow what would you
guys like to know about meadow
oh
that's a pretty funky idea
knight f3 f5 on the re-enigma board
that's uh that's a very interesting way
of meeting the retti uh not one that
i've seen very often
probably never in a in a such a top tier
game
as uh we still don't know who rey enigma
is but i imagine it is either an
incredibly strong
young international master or a grand
master
thank you for the contribution panda
panda
hope you hope you enjoyed some some nice
videos during
all of these years
how am i enjoying life as a father i am
enjoying it very deeply and very very
profoundly
uh
we are we are very happy to have such a
such a healthy young girl
she's already nine months old and well
she so far we we have not had any issues
whatsoever
uh she had like a runny nose for three
days and that's it uh so you really you
know if it remains like this uh
we could have like 10 of them i mean
it's very nice
yeah enigma could be a gm and uh
there was a lot of discussion about this
is he uh one of the gm's but or is he
one of the younger international master
or is he actually more people
i've even seen someone making an
analysis
about enigma being actually four people
at once uh so
i think it's uh hard to
hard to
actually decide uh i don't know
was he ever seen like in two places at
once or was he ever seen like in a
one country today and another country
tomorrow or you know could be could be
interesting
i forgot the two other super chats uh oh
i apologize uh uh as um
they only remained for uh on on the chat
for so long uh i was probably uh
distracted watching what they're doing
in the
in the actual game
so sorry about that
okay but the unit is very close to our
board
so we'll see we'll see what happens
oh yeah
try and guess units move
what are we doing for her first birthday
ah it's a good good good question
units games uh
yeah okay i guess we could do the the
apollo kings gambit game that'd be
that'd be nice i i i think
i need to do a video
and analysis of my daughter's first game
i think she's the well not not very
close to playing her first game
uh might take a few years
like okay i've seen people uh play at
three-year-old but uh uh it's more
like four and a half where they will be
able to actually play the game you know
but even that is that's pushing it
all right udit again uh
walks to our board and it doesn't play a
move maybe the move wasn't yet
transferred that's that's kind of weird
yeah she's now back at anna rudolf's uh
on a rule of stable
uh maybe she's still deciding yeah she
doesn't have to play a move uh once she
gets to our board she can just skip it
i not in thanks for the contribution man
would i like to pronounce uh
yeah no i've uh i've watched a couple of
videos on youtube uh
uh regarding uh pronunciation of
icelandic words and
no
but i i could give it a
like a long stare
although i don't know what the o with
the little dots is uh supposed to be in
in ice landing but i i'm pretty sure
even this is nowhere near
yeah okay but what is the meaning of of
the word that's also very important
hey carlos gospel thanks for the
community
k7 for the community okay we'll see
what's unit plays
if you guys i mean uh is pretty much
everyone is uh
is trolling other streamers with with
king to e7 i guess we we we we can be
the board that doesn't do that but uh
you know i i can't stop you you are of
course always welcome to suggest any
move you want
[Music]
alright some fancy music there
all right so the the community board
will open
very quickly now
they are saying so you guys will be able
to also suggest moves there
all right so i guess we could also
implement the the community board uh
sure
why not
while we're while we're waiting we could
also uh
put the community board in okay let's
just load this up
ah there it is sorry sorry yeah
there's the official stream so this is
the actual board
all right it's uh not of the highest
quality but i think it will it will do i
will uh i will make it fit properly so
don't worry guys it will not look like
this
uh all right so unit uh goes for knight
to b5 where do we where do we stand on
this
you guys uh are of course who we listen
to so whatever you guys suggest
uh do do suggest
so knight to b5 is on the board as we
accept expected what do we go what do we
play
oh everyone suggesting d6 you are you
are all incredibly strong players and
very serious players
all right so uh unit knows theory better
than all of us so maybe maybe we try
something other than uh other than
uh what everyone knows
uh okay i'm getting a lot of kinky
sevens but hopefully uh we
we don't play that
all right a queen to a5 check would uh
would not be a very good idea for us
definitely not all right so yeah okay so
we have uh some very interesting ideas
with a6
yeah a lot of people going for a6 you
really want to play that
you want to play this all right
okay so many so many good suggestions
it's it's very hard to
to decide
yeah but okay
okay it's so it's between d6 and a6 this
is uh
standard whatever one plays this would
be this would be incredibly
incredibly exciting
uh okay but i i think uh too many of you
are writing d6 for me to ignore so d6 it
will be all right
all right
hey daniel alvarez thank you for
remaining a member for four months of
the hoodie guys thank you very much sir
all right so d6 it is
yeah a6 we could play a6 then we we get
our king into the center of the board
and we get uh we got an interesting game
it's definitely
definitely what we can do
all right
what is unit up to
let's just
oh we don't have the unit video anymore
so
who knows what what she's up to
uh but okay we we got our move in
uh what do you guys think of this
oh this will be this will be
uh you were hoping for a more dynamic
position after three moves well this can
get very very dynamic
i mean if we transpose a little bit we
can we could even wind uh in wind up in
uh uh um a morphe versus anderson game
you would like some uh key kga action in
the next game i imagine you are
referring to the king's gambit accepted
uh yes that is uh that is always uh
a good try but uh we played e5
uh okay we played c5 so
yeah maybe she would have gone for this
uh
if we had gone e5 i don't know
do i know the lineup for the zagative
tournament no i i do not know the lineup
by heart i mostly learn the lineup when
when i check out the tournament
ah
this is the name of the volcano that
erupted in 2010 its name translates the
okay asia is island yaya is mountain
jokul is glacier so the
island so the
glacier of the island mountain
or something like that
but yeah i've heard it's uh one of the
more uh one of the more impressive uh
languages that you could pick up
it's not good for us to be anderson in
the game anderson morphy no it it would
not be good for us to be anderson in
that game
federico greetings uh welcome welcome
from the far land of argentina
uh yeah it's hard to say if yuri will
just go for some standard stuff
or
not but
yeah she could
she could pretty much play anything here
bishop should go to g8 that's uh that's
a very weird thing to say
uh you can watch all the games on the
official stream but i don't know if you
can watch all of them at once uh so let
me just uh
see if the community board is already
happening no the community board is not
happening let me just uh
maybe i could introduce it here like
this a little bit uh
just uh yeah i don't know yeah
all right so this is what you would
normally see
yeah okay this is the community board
basically that uh
you see unit again has the brown pieces
here and the majority or rather the
world has the dark blue pieces and here
we will be able to make the moves uh but
that's only
after it starts and it still has uh
hasn't started
all right
uh we should pre-move a6 you say ah
that's a
free move in a correspondence game now i
i don't think no one did that ever in
the history of chess
free move in a correspondence game wow
ah you you're expecting bishop c4 and
castles from unit
uh
i don't think that's very likely as the
unit knows
what is uh the absolute best here uh but
we'll see
yeah of course uh
uh oh you will not have problem with any
of these lines that goes without saying
we should be the first to pre-move a6
yeah what i mean what could happen what
could happen
we should definitely create a novelty
yes we should definitely
create a novelty although
when is when is a good opportunity to do
so
yeah we don't need to lose the fastest
that that's true that's true we don't
need to lose the fastest
how many moves will the game be for who
knows
knight c3 d5 must be stopped or or maybe
it doesn't maybe we allow it like
anderson allowed morphe to get his
knight all the way to d5 he even
sacrificed the bishop on e3
like b3 f5 f4 captures then morphy
completely annihilated him
uh well i knew what board she was at
because i had it on the on the
uh
what's it called
on the voice chat but uh she left
so
it could be that something else is
happening
yeah f5 also good for the next move
there are there are many great ideas
here
you guys i mean i will not uh impose my
will
just because i move the pieces
we will still be here tomorrow in a
queen and pony end game
ah you want some special play with h5h4
i like it i like the way you think
i like it
and well who knows how how you'd it
would would punish us for for such
insolence but it is it is possible to
play like this that is true
and their communities are playing
against
female chess player of all time judith
pogar
okay i just realized i have been
pronouncing polgar uh
improperly this whole time
but it might take me a while to get it
done i don't i don't have this l i don't
think i could i could pull it off
polgar yeah no
uh i will have to i will have to train
for this
no it's not that uh it's not that there
is no time limit we should move within a
minute when unit makes the move but for
unit of course she has to walk around so
it will take her some time to
to play out the moves
yeah peter taught likes the h5 idea huh
you you like the h5h4 idea
just
completely completely wing it huh
yeah of course we we have a suggestion
of queen a5 check and after white moves
the king to e2 then we pick up the
knight that's uh
i don't know why she's still playing
this position i think she can just
resign this
do i like lamb meat i like the the pet
definitely but as i am vegan i i don't
like to eat it if that if that's what
you mean
but maybe you know play with it and
cuddle it yeah that's cool
oh they're saying our board did not make
the move
uh that's uh
very strange
yeah but i i had my suspicions that uh
maybe something wasn't uh
that the moves were not being
transmitted properly
okay so next move we'll make instantly
uh as it uh because the other boards are
already almost finished and we we have
like three moves on the board
no okay i'm kidding they're not they're
not finished but uh
yeah queen a5 king d king e2 and queen
captures on b5 legendary
legendary
so early days
he uh has got a lot of ideas well the
one option but no okay i see on a
crownling's position it's like they made
some four moves so it's nothing
i think it's just uh that it's uh
for the moment is going a bit slower as
they are youth is making uh
uh interviews after every move on every
board and she's talking to to the
cameraman so we'll see
but worry not as long as this takes we
will make a recap of it on our uh
normal normal format
the pronunciation in the
actual gaming pronunciation with a shirt
like shoe but he's pronounced like
an s with zoo
with an s like in zoo
zulu
oh yeah that kind of makes sense yeah oh
haha
zula yeah i messed that up
sorry about that
yeah too early to offer a draw
is my favorite food broccoli no but you
are you are very close uh you are very
close it is actually cauliflower
yeah they're they're stretching out the
event but it's uh it's it was designed
that way uh but i i think after a few
more moves are made then the
situation will will
liven up
oh it's low because unit has to walk uh
or to all the 10 boards and then make
the move
yeah we've shown we've shown tony tony
miles versus karpov i think that one
we've definitely shown
uh
other than that i don't know if we've
shown other tony miles games
ah cauliflower is basically a white
broccoli
well hard to argue with that
yeah yeah we should definitely be aware
of some nasty discoveries from judith
that is that is true
oh it's it's really not too much time i
mean for for a chess game this is uh i
mean this is a simultaneous exhibition
uh this is not uh
like it's not bullet or blitz
you shall now lecture chat on the health
benefits of kale that's the that's the
stuff
water or beer uh they are both essential
they are both essential
yeah a lot of good ideas so so uh we we
are still we'll all depending on the
white and what unit plays but we have uh
uh we have knights to f6 bishop b7
suggested we have a6 suggested we have
uh many suggestions we even have queen
a5 checks suggested we have a h5h4
suggested uh
many many many uh uh well great
suggestions
are we playing at the moment yes at the
moment uh we are playing against yuri's
blogger yes
you it has the cauliflower pieces that
is that is true
did i celebrate saint patrick's day yes
but not
maybe in a way that i would celebrate a
couple of years ago
yes h5h4 very very very popular
a4 so this is a
hit the base which defends the pawn so
you know
okay some analysis of the of the semi
game
yeah i think it's too late for that
dragon all right so we do have c4 c4 is
on the board now
chat whatever you want uh we can go for
it
how do we how do we want to tackle this
yeah you can see meadow but he's always
there sleeping
ah some crazy crazy lines oh i like it i
like it
what do we have all right so all of you
all of you are going for the absolute
main theory i need some more suggestions
i need more suggestions
if we don't want to go with with the
main line uh then we we we have to play
something
all right someone even suggested f4
that's
so like like an f5 f4 thing huh
all right so slow playing it or maybe
like that you got nothing okay
good man that's good enough
all right but let's see let's see how
unit does it alright let's go for it
let's go f5
this is gonna this is gonna be a great
game
let's do this
all right let's see
let's see let's see how it goes
yeah i mean development is overrated
everyone knows that
[Laughter]
yes this will this will crash the
servers definitely
yes yes now with now we slow play it
after f f5 but at least we will see how
how unit will exploit such uh such uh
well the
insolent idea
oh if if this is too much action for you
at this space you are you are welcome to
check out the
the shorter version that we are going to
make
no no uh
too many too many people voted for it
and not for me not to play it but we
can't just play the the absolute main
line that everyone is just gonna write
so
yeah we'll see i mean anderson anderson
played c5
has to be good
all right let's see
where we're at currently
and i think it's time uh it's time for
us to again mention the basics of what
we are doing here because yes this is a
celebration of chess this is a
celebration of great minds and how to
connect them
and also this is a celebration of
obviously one of the
greats judith but we also
trying to create a new world record here
let's tell you all about it let's see
another clip
can we beat the world's strongest female
chess player of all time if we join
forces one board thousands of players
you did will be in the hungary pavilion
at the expo 2020 and you can join the
game online make your moves on the
virtual chess board then the computer
will accumulate the votes and after each
move it will make the most popular one
on the physical board how can you join
register on our website follow the
stream and play let's unite in an epic
game
how to join visit the events website
scroll to vote chess in the upper right
corner sign up by clicking okay so the
the world board still hasn't uh started
i i will uh pull it up when it starts so
you guys can make your moves
but as you can see
by the way which which move do you want
uh on the world board
i guess you guys want e4 i don't even
have to ask that but you know just in
case
just in case we're gonna put that one in
also
yeah bring out the queen to scare you
that that's a good good idea
uh i think all the all the channels are
streaming it pretty much
yeah okay now king e7 after f5 would be
would be very impressive i i have to i
have to agree with you yes
play the retti on the world board
uh i don't know if we can make the moves
just yet no i think nah we still
fast and we were can't discussing while
watching that video that we should join
yeah i'm thinking about joining the 11th
table because uh it's uh so they are
joining it okay fair that we that you
guys are you guys get to play judah than
we do yeah we're just sitting here
talking to all these amazing influencers
and every now and then julie we might
want to jump on the action again now
what the producers have told us is that
we are really getting ready
for that 11th special table to open up
but before we are going to do that let's
just analyze a little bit more because i
know tanya is never going to be out of
suggestions and nice notes that
she had just jutted into her mind so
all right we'll we'll see what she plays
we'll see what's what we'll see what she
plays
oh that's uh
don't snipe
yeah no such thing as sniping in chess
no i don't think we we need to consider
our responses before we we see her her
move uh
so let's let's wait for the move and
then we're gonna it was
coming
unit will be a pro and and snap f5
uh
if we if we played f4 uh
then we would i i think we would seal
our fate much like anderson did against
morphy
all right let's get back to some of the
islamic singer what is that why is sami
playing a different simon on his boat
tell us about that but this is his game
against judith polgar and if he is doing
that he needs to focus on this one
because it's going to heat up really
quickly i have one question for samira
and his community and sagar shah why are
your pieces not out take out some of
those pieces already well e6 on the
board the last move played by them it
simply means that they want to finally
develop with the bishop coming to b4
give a check on to the king to e1 black
has an extra point all right so unit has
captured an f5 unit captures an f5 she
gladly captures this or what do you guys
play
so you
uh you guessed it well that you would go
after the pawn how do we play this
nice and slow or
what do you want here
yeah i see i see a lot of you are
interested in recapturing uh some of you
though are interested in uh just
continuing development which would be
maybe
more in the spirit of uh of of playing
f5
all right
time to sacrifice
all right
yeah i think okay now it's basically
between that and knight to f6 but as
most of you are writing this we are
gonna go with knights to f6 all right
knight to f6 it is you guys you guys
decided it let's do this
all right so we are down a pawn and we
will see what happens
[Laughter]
there's probably a disgusting engine
line we fall into more probably there is
but will we will we get to see it that
is the question
okay what is happening here the approach
that judith will have in this position i
think she's not going to stop i'm
expecting her to continue this pawn
march down the board and the reason for
that is this is a very instructive and a
very interesting moment
white of course wants to try to get
eight six at some point and if black
stops it if black says you know what i'm
going to block that move with my own
pawn then this in chess we call it a
hook
yeah they did get a couple of move more
moves in on that board but
someone says it's a it's a forced mate
in 12. i i very much am
looking forward to seeing that
all right so you place bishop to d3 she
defends the pawn
all right now it's time to to play real
chess what do you guys want here
how do you guys want to continue this
all right i'm getting bishop to e7 in
a6 in okay
oh i i see i see some e4 moves in could
be could be very tricky with uh with the
king still in the center but yeah i
think mostly it's uh
okay
you guys have to decide on it
all right all right keep suggesting keep
suggesting that's that's very nice
oh you want oh wow so many so many wild
suggestions
wow
all right you guys you guys are you guys
talked me into it all right a6 it is
a6 it is then we then we see what's
happening
yeah so we got a lot of suggestions in
uh we got e4 we got d5 we got knight to
b4 we got queen to a5 check bishop to e7
so pretty much every move in existence
was suggested here
uh but this is kind of a developing move
as we are forcing white
uh to move a knight to uh to at least a
less active square
so let's see how how unit will punish us
here
all right there will be time for
everything there will be time for
everything but button to enter the
interface after signing in you will see
the following interface
will play white and the audience will
play black you can see the chessboard on
the left and the previous moves will be
listed
all right
okay we got uh i got the the us feed
back on so now i think they are going to
start moving seriously
only question is do we lose first uh
well if we do it's gonna be a game to
remember and one that we can
use the
well
teach future generations how how not to
play chess maybe
but this is still a
a feisty position
oh
night before bishop e2 knights to d4
yeah that's uh okay so she goes back
knight to c3
nothing too crazy
what do you guys want
is the world bored on
nope world board still is uh
waiting to be played all right wow so
many
so many of you uh
insta playing bishop to e7 okay this is
uh without uh
without even waiting for it we have to
play this all right
yes yes bishop to be bishop to e7 played
all right
oh it's almost already back at our board
so i think now the positions are are
happening much much faster so okay i
guess it's not like in a regular
simultaneous exhibition where she would
go to a board and then if no move was
made then uh
you would kind of lose a point and you
have three of these points that you can
use so you always have to make your move
before
unit reaches the board but now i think
she's just sort of uh freestyling it
through all the boards and then when she
sees a move being made then she plays
against it
and it's uh i guess it's a little bit
harder since there are no actual people
there she's playing against 10 empty
boards the moves are automatic
yes well said todd win there is no
brilliancy without blunders that's
that's true
okay so we have castle as a suggestion
and a prepare to castle as a suggestion
as she she either castles or plays
bishop to g5 yeah we'll see
and we'll see what are we going to do
with our
uh
well with being down upon but it's not a
uh not something that we have to stress
about
uh
at any point yeah i guess once we castle
knight to b4 can be can be played and we
can harass the bishop then maybe we can
maybe we can but it's going to be hard
to get the d5 in at any point but yeah
i see what you guys are saying yeah it's
going to be it's going to be an
interesting game
yeah okay knight to b4 definitely uh is
a likeable move but uh we should maybe
finish development first
yes queen c7 is always good in sicilian
uh unless unless it's not
we are never getting that pawn back
it's okay it's okay we don't uh we don't
need all of our pawns
yeah it all depends on what she plays
where are we
okay so they are uh having some some
more interviews
yeah and also it's it's a double death
pawn let's not let's not forget about
that it's not gonna be easy to convert
this
it will be it will be somewhat easy
against us but if uh if you guys play
well could be
could be very interesting
no i have no doubt that the game will be
extremely interesting regardless of uh
of uh how it continues because we've
chosen a very interesting idea
isn't knight d5 good for unit i
well it could be
yeah it could be but uh
we'll see we'll see if she if she goes
for it
okay yuri plays g4 she goes uh she goes
for the for the aggressive approach
uh now everything is
everything is in the air
so she is not giving up uh she's not
giving us that that pawn back uh
she says this is now this is now
uh
a very a very nice position for white
but also doesn't have to be true what do
you guys what do you guys want here
all right i have some some very cool
ideas
yeah okay well it's very principled to
go d5 i guess on a flanker tank we
should reply with a with a strike in the
center
i'm getting a lot of h5s
a lot of e5s yeah many many okay the the
e5 is already on the board
we should castle first yeah okay we're
we're either castling or we're playing
h5 we can play both
so what do you guys want
uh knights to b4 in a situation like
this might be a little bit tricky
wow so much so much d5
all right
wow even that even that okay
ah so you want to you want to play this
slowly
all right
the h point is it is just uh i just have
to check whether you want it to h6 or to
h5 do you want to really open up the
position or or play it really slowly
okay
we are playing h6 alright you guys win
this will not be pleasant at all
okay so your plan is to make her over
extend on the king's side i see okay
we're gonna we're gonna go with that
we are done for
well
more people uh seem to have been been
typing h6 that's why i had to play h6
ah there wasn't a good option just a l
less bad option
a lesser option if you will
why haven't we castled yet well no one
is no one is suggesting castles it's
very very simple
no there aren't polls in youtube
streaming and i decided not to use poles
for the simple reason because if people
just check their engines they would vote
for the strongest move and then i would
always have to play the strongest move
this way you guys get to suggest and i
can pick uh any moves so of course uh
some of the suggestions are engine moves
but uh this way i think it's it's a bit
more fair
yes yes we will do an analysis of the
video afterwards uh and then we will see
all the all the great moves that we have
missed
to play
ah no castle no castle we strike against
the whites uh white's forces okay
yeah but the white king is also naked in
the center of the board we also have to
take that into consideration
if we ever castle it must be queen side
all right
a lot of a lot of very good suggestions
here
uh but even uh more important is the to
make the suggestion when it matters
that's the that's the real
uh real um
uh important thing
ah you we should surprise you and not
castle at all all right
so knights to d4 is always an option
that definitely that's well said yeah
nice knight on d4 would uh would serve a
very nice purpose
uh but we still have to wait and see
what unit plays
uh you so you are expecting h4 and you
are expecting this to be a
just a you know a nice old old-school
barbarian attack
uh yes i imagine it will be so
yeah so okay we have uh we we decided
not to go too aggressive with h5 or
rather most of you did that's why we
played it then we are either castling
king's side into the pawn storm which
kind of doesn't look all that great or
another suggestion from you is the
develop the queen develop the bishop and
then castle queen side so all very very
good ideas we still have to wait and see
what unit plays and then we are going to
decide how are we proceeding here
let's start the king march too or too
early a little bit for the king march
how about not castling at all yes those
are all all very valid options yeah
uh but we have to decide on one of them
do we have okay judit is at our board
she's very impressed with our h6 move i
can see by her impression
she's extremely impressed and she is
okay so she she goes bishop to e3 she
doesn't go for your plan of just h4 g5
which makes sense it's a very nice idea
uh taking uh care of some very important
squares of b6 also knight to d5 when it
comes will be
joined with the b6 and the c7 square so
many
many great uh things happening here for
white so how do we proceed this do we
still play it cool keep the king in the
center do you guys want to
what do you guys want
yes obviously there's a there's a nice
uh the d5 is always very popular
especially now maybe if d5 can be played
then if captures captures if everything
gets traded off the board uh then if
queen captures on d5 will already be
attacking the rook here so that's uh
kind of goes in our favor
and i'm i'm startled by how many of you
guys are playing are riding
d5 you guys really want this
knight to d5 in super slow motion
yeah
okay so some of you want a castle uh and
then face units armies
some of you want knight to d4 those are
all very very nice options
wow you guys really want this d5 move
huh it's gonna be crazy
yeah everyone likes d5
okay so
ah but but you also want to keep it
flexible with queen to a5 i see
wow these are all these are all very
good suggestions
okay there's even a b5 there all right
okay you guys convinced me let's do it
let's go d5
you guys convinced me
all right so
we'll see
this inclusion of g4 is incredibly
impressive will it prove to be the the
correct way to go
it's hard to say
yes we are striking in the center
we often say that if we play d5 uh and
we don't lose the game then we are very
good
don't open the center of the board why
not we are we are playing the sicilian
we have to play d5
b5 also yes b5 was also a valid valid
suggestion
we've already given up one pawn maybe
giving up the other one is a bit too
scary at the moment
g6 what is what is g6
yeah white queen can come to d4 although
oh to a4 but it's not uh
we don't really have any issues with
that
am i worried about disappointing eudic
in in what regard
oh i i did ask judith as i've spoken to
her before uh before a few days ago i i
said maybe it would be better if we just
played you know ourselves without the
community that it will be hard to
evaluate who is uh
you know using outside assistance but
she said that no no she wants the she
wants to play against all the
communities and that uh
we are
definitely able to play uh to play a
nice game uh without any weird stuff
happening so that's why
uh it this is the format that we we went
for
all right
would an engine play like us i i
seriously doubt it i seriously doubt it
alright so she captures
i imagine you guys want to recapture
this but uh you know
i am also
waiting on your suggestion so
i imagine you guys want night captures
uh knight captures on the e5
yeah
oh just a recapture oh it's very
dangerous to write recapture the queen
captures on d5 is also a recapture
but okay this is what you guys want all
right so i think this is pretty
unanimous
all right so this is now
very very
very interesting
it's almost impossible to predict what
happens next
as that dark square bishop on e3 is
looking very very odd
uh
yeah i'm very much interested in in what
will happen here
mehmed amin thank you for the
contribution man
with a message try
oh
oh that would be
f6 ah
i don't know
where are we currently here let me just
check real quickly
uh
was waiting to see if they will be
uh yeah okay we can't really show them
discussing our position that would be
that would be a little bit weird
as we are still playing it
yeah bishop to h4 at some point i guess
is a valid attempt uh
since black is not castling kingside we
don't want to see h4 on the board so
this would be okay
but we already developed this bishop and
there are
other pieces to develop
however i will of course let you guys do
the moves
you you are saying unit will
you
okay so the night captures
just as i just as i thought
i imagine you guys want to recapture i i
guess i can recapture this without even
consulting with you
because it's kind of the only move
yeah
yeah she missed f6 alright so we're
capturing this
alright so maybe she maybe she misses
that her rook is hanging and then we can
win the game this way
if this happens then we are okay
okay aside from it being muted that
we're playing if
if if i had this position like against
anyone i would be very happy even being
down upon
not too happy but you know i wouldn't be
sad
ah yes the the rook to a7 brilliancy
yeah i mean who knows okay she is
currently at our board she is marveling
at our position as we are playing so
elegantly and so originally
uh and she is uh
well pondering on what to play
[Music]
this will be this will truly be a great
game
so other than by moving the rook or so
moving the rook or castling is pretty
much the only option she has here
so we can expect one of the two
no i don't think she plays knight to c3
no she will not uh she will she will not
let us take the game like this
oh so now you are all saying you like
our position yeah
so so far you were just writing ah
resign resign resigned
ah
once she makes a move bishop g5 yeah
there are
many ideas to consider here
hmm
all right so still no moose on the
world's board
um okay judith is uh taking her time on
our board yeah she is very impressed
with our queen on d5 and who wouldn't be
such a beautifully centralized queen for
the price of one pawn
uh
yeah this is uh definitely something
else
yeah
yeah
i remember when someone said it it was
not the dynamic enough but okay it was
unit who made it dynamic by playing g4
uh even though
it was maybe not necessary and we we did
throw in that f5 move which was uh maybe
a bit too much but
is there a chance we win this uh highly
highly unlikely but we are we are having
a good time and we are enjoying our
position
we play the sicilian defense we managed
to push d5 and we have a queen on d5
already
i don't know
what could make us
like as happy as we are now so you know
life is just good
all right
no she's still at our board she's the
she's really marveling at our position
yeah i think uh
i think this only proves uh how strong
the f5 idea was
f5 g4 h6 wow that's uh that's really
something else
yeah we also have a bishop pair although
it's not as impressively developed
yeah she's looking for a quick checkmate
yeah could we
yeah our bishops are so weak but that
can change very very quickly
like uh once we once we decide what we
will do with our king
uh
anything is possible like even even a
nice b5 bishop to b7 although that might
be
over pushing it it all depends on what
she plays
it's uh it's a very very weird position
maybe she's thinking about a move like
king the e2 that could also be
happening then the queen guards the rook
uh the king is in a nice
safe
square surrounded by the bishop pair and
then she just continues pushing and
crushes us good also a possibility
yeah f3 f3 is not happening but but nice
king e2 i'm not ruling this out
yeah meadow is sleeping but uh
it's uh
well if he doesn't wake up for a game
like this then i don't know what what he
will do
why not f3 well i i don't know just
bishop h4 seems uh
too much to allow black of course
why did we let this pawn here well we
kind of had to try something to
then not just play mainline moves so we
we gave up a pawn
for interesting play
and the
unit is still okay i think you did is
making a move yeah she made a move so we
should be seeing it fairly quickly here
if that was our board
yeah you did castled all right so we
have castles
it means that we are not going to face a
kingside attack but it also means that
we could also maybe castle kingside get
our bishop to this diagonal and then use
this diagonal to will sort of wreak
havoc but uh
i will of course let you guys decide on
that how do you how do you want to play
this
all right so i'm seeing a lot of castles
i'm seeing a knight to d4
i'm i'm not uh
for the moment interested in a knight d4
that would be really weird
knight b4 we should kind of continue
developing there's really no reason to
go for that bishop just yet
um
yeah but i mean
now
yeah knight b4 wow everyone so many
people suggesting knights to b4 that's a
it's an extremely weird move to suggest
uh
so you guys want to trade this and go
into an end game and did not play
wow that's very interesting very
interesting
all right all right
all right i'm
all right some b5 some e4s you guys are
basically suggesting every move there is
in chess
i like it
i like that you are doing that
all right all right all right okay okay
so it's important for everyone to get
their suggestion in
so okay basically it's uh between
castles and the immediate b5 wow
so basically between castles the
immediate b5 and knight b4 of course
those are those are the options yes and
the plans are clear so are we afraid of
leaving the king in the center uh
castling puts our king and queen on the
same diagonal and then a move like a
developing move might put us to great
risk here so maybe castling here is uh
maybe a bit too much
uh and maybe she could exploit this uh a
little bit too easy
yeah yeah all right so
you guys are definitely correct about
this yeah it's uh all very good i mean
we have to check for blunders but yeah i
see what you guys are are implying
yeah okay
all right i
agree that knight to b4 is the way to go
i don't know i was uh i was too scared
to play castles i i have to say i mean
it just did not feel right
uh
castling did not feel right
okay so luckily we don't blunder our
queen here uh as the knight defends the
queen but uh castling here putting the
king and queen on the same diagonal with
the light square bishop still in the
game
it really
looked
like something we shouldn't do maybe
yes action on the board could be better
but
now at least we've moved the knight from
c6 and now if uh
well i imagine i imagine we have to
trade queens now but we are going to i i
imagine get our bishop to this diagonal
and then
hmm
too much light square weaknesses we'll
see
we shall see
yeah the problem is you can't really
play bishop e2 if bishop to e2 then we
just trade okay so yeah bishop can also
capture then the c2 square is covered
yeah
so it's a
it's a it's a position
she's gonna play queen to a4
while this is possible i don't see how
it does anything other than develop our
bishop
so i i i don't think we'll be seeing
queen a4
yeah she will play bishop to e2 or
something like this probably
uh
yeah and then we maybe we go bishop c6
followed by this or something like this
you guys will decide ultimately
you actually can play b5 after queen to
a4
yeah if this b5 uh
you you can't capture really because the
queen is also guarding this
but we don't need b5 we can just play
the bishop
uh i'm not seeing where unit is
currently
yeah she could do she could do a lot of
things
oh there are actually games in the
database that reach this position how
nice
uh the time control is correspondence so
infinite time or rather infinite for
unit
ah someone is saying she's on our board
she's uh
deciding on what to do all right
yeah obviously knights the c3 will not
be played we are threatening to win a
piece here so uh the only option for
unit is to move the bishop
and the only squares uh to do so are
bishop e2 and bishop to c2
with bishop to e2 making a bit more
sense as well the bishop on c2 just
[Music]
gets under attack by by the knight so
maybe maybe not not all that impressive
yeah i'm not uh i'm not thrilled about
trading queens here
so we're gonna have to think really
really deeply in order to in order
to keep the queens on the board
which is
which is very scary
yeah i i don't see anything better than
just whatever she plays bishop d7 and
long castles
so
yeah other than other than
other than bishop to e2 i don't see a
move for white and then we have to
decide do we still keep the queens on
or do we try to
no or do we trade or do we try to keep
the queens on
i don't think uh
yeah it's maybe maybe wasting too many
moves
yeah but after bishop they do how do you
how do you keep the queens on
it's not easy the bishop pair is very
very strong
uh for the moment we cannot play bishop
to g4
yeah
yeah we're going to have to figure out
something
we can't uh
we can't not trade queens but we can't
really trade queens
i mean
we are down a pawn so we don't want to
rush any sort of an end game
yes we
of course we have an advantage due to
our centralized queen but after
a move like bishop to e2
how do you keep the queens on the board
that's the real question
any further centralizing idea might run
into knight c3 so we're just gonna get
harassed
and if queen back to c6 we take away a
nice valuable square for for our bishop
and also the knight it's looking a bit
weird but okay we could consider
something like bishop e2 queen c6
then whatever white plays yeah it's just
looking a little bit weird
trade queen's nh5 yeah
yeah okay that uh that does make sense
yeah
no you don't trade the rook because
after let's say bishop e2 trade queens
bishop captures here in bishop character
c2 so we we cannot uh
we cannot strap the rook this way
yeah that's my thought exactly after
bishop e2 we just go bishop to d7
and uh well
if she wants to trade which i don't
think she wants probably knight c3 she
will force us to capture so she gets the
open file for
for her rook yeah bishop to e2 is played
and then we will be having this maybe
bishop to c6 move so this is possible
but uh
also possible it's just that after
bishop d7 bishop to f3 is played and
what then
yeah it's all very very interesting but
yeah bishop to d7
i don't know you guys decide
you guys decide
yeah okay so a lot of you do enjoy uh
okay some of you are interested in
actually capturing on d1 some of you are
interested in bishop to d7
some of you are interested in queen to
f7 that's uh
very very interesting
yeah that's uh super awesome
yeah so you guys really wanted this i'm
bishop to d7
yeah also one of the one of the ideas
just straight and h5 yeah force
force g5 yeah but then the f5 is is very
weak so this is also possible if we want
to if we want to rush into the end game
very very interesting
all right
you guys you guys have decided bishop to
d7 it is all right there we go
uh bishop to f3 isn't really all that
impressive because we can always just
trade or we can even block with e4 so
it's not
not something spectacular
yeah i imagine
i imagine knight to c3 is definitely an
idea
it will be
a nice tempo on our queen
but that's kind of what we were going
for knight c3 we capture she captures
and then we put a bishop on c6 and we
are very very happy with our uh bishop
on this impressive diagonal with her
bishop on e2 if this happens so we we
will be happy with this
uh so i kind of don't think that this is
what we will see
yeah maybe this is uh
yeah after this yeah captures captures
or something like that bishop to c6 we
we are happy being down upon with the
light square bishop here
not ecstatic but i mean it is you that
we are playing so we we can only be
happy with anything we get
yeah our queen is better but uh
trying to trying to keep the queen here
would be just uh forcing her to uh to a
bad square
plus you could make uh you could make a
remark for anything i guess but we are
we are in this together and i have to
make a decision on your guys suggestions
uh you think i should pre-move the queen
trade i don't know i wouldn't be so sure
how many games are still on i don't know
we can quickly check this
okay so some interviews happening uh the
world board is still not
operational
all right
someone tweeted to me with a photo of
their child and cat sleeping on them
while watching the stream so hello to
you sir mr mario thomas
thank you for such a nice
share
yeah so it's uh
the reason why i don't think yeah
knight to c3 is maybe the best is that
we get this diagonal for our bishop
bishop
to f3 right away
it's probably the best
but
again it's hard to say
then many things become possible
yeah then then maybe even bishop f3 e4
could be nice then you put white in an
awkward spot if queen just trades the
knight captures then we get a tempo on
the dark square bishop so that can be
very pleasant uh
because we want to we want to win the
bishop pair and the bishop has to move
all the way back so that would be
unpleasant we had a nice castle move in
so
uh i don't like knight c3 for white i
i'm not convinced in bishop to f3 i
don't think queen captures on d5 is
great but white is always up upon so
uh
we have to
we have to uh
well respect that but yeah at some point
h5 will be played we will try to weaken
the f5 pawn we will try to capture this
open up the h file so those are some of
the ideas that we have
ah
uh chronologino is informing me that our
chess club has defeated the opposing
chess club with a very very narrow
margin
very good very good
we we are the greatest
all right so still no sign of unit some
interviews are happening so
if anyone has eyes on you did
feel free to inform us whether she's uh
i should have worn a hoodie as i'm
representing all of you
okay could be
uh could be the case yeah
uh we should just offer a draw uh
i don't know i might be a bit too too
quick to offer a draw
yeah so yeah we still haven't castled
but uh
yeah uh
so those are kind of the candidate moves
but you did surprised us with g4 so she
might surprise us again
yeah so like we okay bishop f3 queen
captures a knight to see three are kinda
the candidate moves and we are not
worried about either of them as we've
discussed
uh if we trade the knight for the bishop
it will fix her pawn structure that is
true but we will have the bishop pair
and if we point them imagine if this
bishop is gone and pawn upon captures
the bishop here
then imagine if our bishop gets hold of
this diagonal and if this bishop gets
hold of this diagonal then we will
definitely have compensation for our
pawn
or
we will have something as close to
compensation as we can get
what if she plays a3 oh that's a that's
a disgusting thing to say why would why
would you even say that wow
uh that's the
yeah that's uh a3 is uh
is the move to consider definitely uh a3
i believe forces a queen trade
and then after bishop captures which is
also kind of forced we get
knight to c2 no longer works so we can
go back here
uh attack the bishop
attack of the bishop here or we can even
play knight the d3 if this means
something to us
for some reason
as the bishop is on d1 so our knight
cannot get kicked away right away we we
will be putting pressure on the
beat you pawn so
too many options here too many options
to discuss
before she actually plays a move
ah yeah okay
uh on a3 bishop to c6 threatening mate
also
a move to consider yeah
yeah maybe maybe a nice in-between move
yeah
i don't have uh eyes united so i don't
know if she is uh at our board but i
imagine she is
as we are playing so uh elegantly
uh let's see what's currently happening
maybe some positions are being discussed
you know
it's so easy because you just try to
imagine her
storming into the studio and be like
watch out it's my move
all right so unit uh
strikes us with knight to c3
all right knight to c3 on the board what
do you guys like
what do you guys like do you want to
over push this and keep the queens on
the board or do you want to trade and
just position our bishop nicely on this
diagonal like we've prepared so those
are those are basically the options
uh someone suggested queen f2 that's uh
that's a fine suggestion
yeah i i see a lot of queen captures on
d1 queen captures and d1 reluctantly
queen captures on d1 advance the king
okay
yeah
but the problem is if we move our queen
somewhere
inconsiderate then we just allow bishop
to f3 rook to c1 and she's just gonna
destroy us so
capturing the queen here is uh i believe
the only way to go
um all right so that's what we are doing
yeah but there were there were very
interesting uh
decisions to be made uh for her
in the in the sense of yeah everything
we've discussed like bishop to f3 also
just knight to c3a3 so all very very
interesting ideas
ah yeah also if we if we just played
queen f7 then g5 is possible just
opening up this diagonal
which would be very interesting
okay so now we are down upon
and that is not going away
and we are okay so far we only discussed
bishop characters on d1 because
well if if knight to c2 then we can win
the bishop pair but maybe there's
something that you did uh calculated
that uh
allows her to just bring the rook into
the game
maybe maybe that's an option as well
and also it's uh it's very important to
put the bishop on this diagonal i would
say before white unit puts her bishop on
this diagonal
so we're down upon at least we should
have a better bishop pair
yeah nine hours later
uh yeah okay if we're captures obviously
we will discuss maybe night here and
then after she moves the rook we capture
the bishop and then we play bishop to c6
and then we are fully happy with our
position regardless being down upon
uh but we we will wait uh to see what
unit plays i mean that's that's the only
way to
uh
yeah we'll see if long castling is still
even an idea
uh once those rooks come on uh d1 and c1
uh maybe we we will not be so happy here
uh but yeah with uh without the f pawn
her light square bishop will come on
this diagonal which is also very very
good
so we will have a good bishop here
although her bishop here will be
very very impressive
yeah we don't want to fix our structure
but for the bishop we will
for the bishop we will i believe
yeah uh all of the all of the moves uh
makes sense we just have to wait and see
what she plays and then we're gonna
discuss
[Music]
all right so you did of course captures
with the a pawn now she grabs hold of
the open c file
uh what do you guys play here
yeah okay well captures with the rook
why
why did we not discuss this
yeah we were sure that if bishop doesn't
capture the knights the c2 is just uh
extremely good for us
for some reason we
we did not
take this into consideration
yeah so the
the idea is now okay that rook a to d1
was played so we either castle here
uh connect the rooks and then
or or bishop to c6 but if bishop to c6
could be very dangerous after bishop to
c4 our king stays in the center after
bishop c4 cutting our king off and the
rook cutting off the
[Music]
the the long castles could be very very
tricky
yeah those of you writing resign that's
super helpful
okay let's just do a really quick check
yeah this is not not the the best
yeah okay for the moment the bishop
remains
yeah okay bishop c6 it is but
maybe not maybe not it's just such a
yeah okay i i see what you guys i see
what you guys want but we also have to
take into consideration something like
bishop c4 the e6 could be
could be very annoying
uh
all right all right you you want it you
have it
you have it
now a3 does not scrap the knight we just
play knight c2 attack the bishop and
then we shift it over to d4 this is
actually a good square for the knight so
we we plan to do this either way
uh regardless of what white plays so
i i don't think we wanted to to get our
knight back
either way
yeah i don't know why everyone is so
worried about the night i i
imagine the knight is perfectly fine
here
like just knight c6 the d4
yeah could be hmm
yes
we have chosen death yeah
no i i don't think even if we offer the
draw i don't think unit would accept a
draw
maybe if we
like if we somehow
if she actually plays a three and maybe
we play knight c2 and pick up the the
bishop so if we win the bishop pair here
and offer a draw
she might she might grace us with a draw
but i don't see it
happening uh what if rook d2
yeah okay
that kind of takes away the c2 square
from our uh
from our good friend the knight but then
uh then we can just play rook d8 and we
are we are happy with this
maybe
yeah yeah rook d2 might be an issue
yes why no one why did no why didn't
anyone uh say anything about this
yeah if rogue d2 taking away the c to
square from our knight we could play
rogue d8 uh but then
yeah then rook rook the other rook comes
to the d file she doubles up
and then what that that is the question
we still didn't get rid of the bishop
pair hmm
uh
yeah we're gonna
have to try somehow but yeah
but okay it's our plan all along we're
down upon and we want to try and trade
night for bishop that's our plan so if
uh if if she plays this
we can offer a rook trade and if she
goes to double up then we can play
not much
not much indeed
so our best bet is that she doesn't she
doesn't go rook d2 or maybe there's even
a stronger move we are not considering
yeah uh we don't really have time for b5
bishop to b7 or
or
i don't think there's a there's a reason
for us to play this
yeah yeah okay obviously a5 is always an
option
and then we can just go back if if such
a move happens we we don't want to play
it but
uh yeah
as long as our bishops are doing a fine
job of guarding these squares uh we
don't we don't have to worry about the
rooks doubling up on the defile all that
much uh what we have to worry about is
that at some point uh
she will probably manage to trade off
the those bishops and then we will lose
control of these squares and then her
rooks that are doubled on the d file
might be very very good
but that's uh you know for for the
future to think about this
so we will only be worried if we see
rook d2 on the board other than that
yeah uh i mean of course there are other
moves to be worried about
yeah if rook d2
yeah we have to start considering some
crazy ideas like like a5
yeah we didn't we didn't really put our
knight to to the best possible square
yeah maybe that whole night to be for
business was a bit too too optimistic
but okay i mean if we played only the
best moves we would be
in in different places
all right so still no moves uh no idea
what is happening uh let me just check
okay unit is having an interview for
currently so you did how was
the last two hours how do you feel
yourself
first of all i'm very happy to be here
it's a very unique location there are
tons of people outside the last few days
of the expo but this pavilion is also
very beautiful so now it's all mine it's
only chess
and uh there are a lot of interesting
things are happening and it's very
really touching for me that
there's so many communities and the
world can also play with me and we can
play together as chess is a language for
all of us
yes so maybe this is really the time
that we lets the game begin so
can i
make my move and i decide if i keep it
or not okay go ahead so let's let's see
and
my move is done i keep that yes
thank you
so as you've heard the first move has
been made on the world board that's why
we've been waiting a little bit
uh
yeah and the e4 move is here so while
we're waiting for you to make uh the
move on our board you guys are also
welcome to vote on what you want to play
on the world board
as there is a vote in progress so
uh we can we can do both of both of them
at once
okay but first uh
ah unit makes the rook to d2 move as
soon as she finishes with the interview
all right so
uh before we decide on the world board
uh what do what do you guys want here on
our board
the situation is not
spectacular
but
we have to we have to decide on on how
to approach this
hmm
all right a5 it is
uh although it's a terrible move to make
uh our position is now
our position is now officially worse but
uh we we
we are the ones that made it so we will
have to suffer through it all right so
the world board is live what what move
do you guys want on the world board
we are not we are not getting a draw
that's for sure
what do you want on the world board
okay it's it will not be our move there
will be a vote in progress uh but yeah
you guys also want to see five okay so
uh
c5 i imagine is what people enjoy the
most
okay but how do we make the move
why can't we make it maybe maybe i have
to reload the page
no
um
[Music]
it's very interesting
the board does not allow us to vote uh
is there any oh i don't suppose you have
to register first or log in
yeah i think maybe you have to log in to
this website to be able to make the
moves as
the moves
are not not happening
no i'm not logged into this
but oh okay it's an e4 e5
you can see uh below that there's uh
there's a graph and it says how many
times the
uh e5 moves were suggested so 41 percent
of times our c5
vote would not be all that impressive
yeah yeah yeah she's too scared to let
us play white
but no seriously for those of you who
might not know this
the the person who holds the
simultaneous exhibition is always white
on all the boards so that's not uh
not even a question
ah the website is i've put the website
in the description of the of the live
stream you can just click on it it's uh
jp
vs the world or your blogger versus the
world dot hungary expo 2020. huh
and that's that's how
you can play this
yeah but obvi it seems that you have to
register or might be some sort of a way
of voting that i
uh failed to grasp
but yeah let me just check if now we
have viewed it on the
stream somewhere
no we don't
no we don't but that's fine
all right if anyone has any idea on the
whereabouts of viewed it
feel free to share but yeah this is now
very very unpleasant
this is not very unpleasant because here
i imagine
many moves can be made for white but
knight to b5 also looks incredibly
unpleasant
maybe
we can survive this but uh if if we give
up the bishop pair then
i don't see it happening
yeah okay a rook d8 but if rook d8 rook
uh rook after d1 and then again you you
you don't really get to play knights to
d5 that's uh that's not happening
yeah now there are many many great ideas
for white okay she goes for a3 right
away
uh so forcing us to take that
that a6 square very interesting
i i was expecting knight to b5 right
away but now okay you guys suggest what
you want to do
uh but
there aren't all that many squares that
we can use yeah
yeah we have to go back unfortunately
unfortunately we have to go back
okay
so now knight to b5 isn't as impressive
since we are covering this square
but again you might have ideas of going
to d6 so
bishop can come to c4 cut us off
completely
i don't like where this is going
yeah
all of a sudden from liking our position
to suddenly being
destroyed
no that of course there is no evaluation
bars this is an actual game this is not
an analysis
okay now if we can get the knight to c5
then we're talking uh we're not talking
much but we are talking
uh
we'll see
so i don't know
i mean obviously she has something
spectacular planned
but i i i would be
much more unhappy if knight to b5 was
played instead of this move
but we'll see
yeah b3 good outpost for the night
definitely
definitely
uh well no because i don't know we we do
not want to trade the bishop for bishop
we want to get our knight to the best
possible square uh and uh
hopefully uh somehow provoke her into
capturing that's not really happening as
there's no reason for her to do this but
i uh bishop c5 also doesn't look that
that impressive
ah that's that's how she'll do it she
goes after our bishop this way
oh and the knight can also get to the b6
square
very nice very nice
oh
all right
so many many impressive threats here
what do you guys want
what do you guys want to see here
ah you wanna you wanna keep everything
on the board with bishop to d8 and then
what knight the b8 attacks the rook rook
to b8 oh
oh that's that's brave that's very brave
yeah i i like your style i like your
style
yeah you also have to be careful
yeah you you want to play just captures
huh and but then our our pieces are
stuck here we we can't really get
anything in
i'm getting a bishop the c5 bishop to d8
uh the slow suffering approach i like
that i'm very fond of the slow suffering
approach
okay rook to d8 also very very
impressive
okay so that's how you want to play it
all right
okay so no slow suffering rook to d8 it
is okay
all right
you you have decided
so our plan to keep the bishop pair in
the game
has not worked out all that great
we'll we'll see how this one goes
let me just check what's happening here
one percent awarded for caro khan a few
wanted the carrow on the board but
all right so still
uh i don't know if any of the games have
finished but the moves are coming in a
little bit a little bit faster
okay but that's uh far from the worst
thing that can happen to us
it's not great but
yeah it's not it's not the worst
okay so she doubles up as you guys
probably expected
so what do you want here that's that's
the real question
yeah okay castling not really an option
since our bishop would be hanging here
so we can't really play that
someone suggests c5 where there's not a
c pawn on the board
but yeah this is uh this is definitely
possible
oh yeah bishop g5 could be very nasty
because imagine if bishop g5 she
captures weak capture and she delivers
knight to c7 check and there goes uh
either our rook here or if we move the
king then she can just pick up a pawn
here with captures capture so
this would be very very very interesting
because i see a lot of you are
suggesting bishop to g5 i could be
missing stuff of course
um
king king to f7 and just trade
everything off huh
yeah knights the c5 can't really be
played she just removes the defender of
the knight so that's not gonna work
so many so many uh so many good options
yes
yeah we've got nothing better
all right
you win rook captures knight
it's not great but none of our options
are
oh this is a very very tough very tough
now it was a it was a good pawn
sacrifice i i liked the idea uh just not
the follow-up uh i think uh
that night the
that night move really cost us a lot
maybe we should have just castled or
maybe went for a full aggressive
approach with h5 who knows
who knows but at least we
we really tried very hard
and we are still fighting
yes we are we are killing it that is
true
we have reached uh we have reached far
into the end game
oh no this is still there there's still
so much to be done here
oh
elena brought me a snack uh it's a very
it's a very nice one but uh maybe if she
if she if only she brought it before we
we got into this difficult end game
uh but you know you take what you can
all right
we have to we have to eat very very
silently
if meadow sees us eating then we will
not be able to get rid of him
all right so still waiting i think judit
might again be very impressed with our
move
or maybe she's just giving an interview
uh let's quickly check on what's
happening
um
ah sama is sama is giving an interview
so i guess their game is over
or maybe they're just having an
interview mid-game could also be
possible
is castling an option now well a lot a
lot of things
are possible
but i imagine after rook captures we
have to recapture rook captures here
again she gains full control over the c5
square so we're not getting our knight
out of there
uh
so we have to really
really pick our options carefully
plus uh this okay so you guys uh of
course choose the choose the move but uh
as bishop captures d5 is the only move
that's what we have to play
and now it will not be easy
as she is uh well
i don't imagine that she's looking
forward to the capturing this night but
uh it's definitely an option uh if she's
up a punch she can further mess up our
pawn structure but i think she will keep
the bishop pair and just keep harassing
us plus uh
the the the
you know just the matter of defending
the
the e5 pawn remains
so we can play something like a bishop
to f6 but that's not a great bishop
there
then we have the pawn uh preventing our
king from going here our bishop will be
here
uh
once her bishop pair becomes fully
operational we are we are completely
doomed so i don't see this game lasting
very long
but we'll see at least we will get to
see how she will
uh how she will do it
yeah 97 in castles are all good moves
but our our pawn here will be hanging
buddy okay after castles if she captures
the pawn we could go bishop f6 kind of
put pressure here but there's just so
much for the rook to do here this is
hanging this is hanging this is uh
i know we'll we'll see a move or two and
then i think we can
call it a call of the day
yeah bishop f6 is a must but
hmm
yeah we
we have to get our lone rook involved
somehow
yeah okay i'm very very much looking
forward to to analyzing this game to see
uh if there is any merit to our pawn
sacrifice
there shouldn't be but
i i really did like our position at one
point after the sacrifice
after that the g4 h6 business so
no our knight is far from great our
knight is far from great
hmm
just kink to the seventh rank no need to
castle yeah but doesn't really change
anything and uh it it it allows rook to
d7 so it could be
uh we we can resign gracefully after
rook captures on d5 yeah that's also
uh that's also not out of the question
yeah resigning gracefully after rook
captures on d5 is also not out of the
question if there is no no poison to
explore
because this is just too too big of a
big of a weakness
both both the pawns will be hanging yeah
no i i wouldn't resign if there was
anything to fight for
i always fight until the very end but
here there's just nothing
people don't like the idea of offering a
draw it would be too disrespectful
but yeah
[Music]
no i'm thinking this is it once the once
the bishop is captured i'm i'm afraid we
will have to resign
okay let me let me check just one more
time if we are
hmm
no there is there is nothing here
uh let me check if uh
photos of where you're playing from send
us a share with us
yeah for some reason i lost the the unit
stream
so we cannot see her
hmm
uh there is no there is no use polgar
versus the world too but how is this
game going let's check out uh how how
the
world board is is doing so e4 e5 knight
f3 knight c6 bishop b5 a6 knight f6 okay
so just the standard standard stuff in
the ruy lopez
uh nothing too
too flashy
so i imagine
uh
this will be incredibly incredibly
precise yeah my uh thoughts were that
the world board will be
uh the most precise board of all the
boards
as people are just voting via their
smartphones for the moves so
uh yeah it's
it should be the the absolute strongest
board
uh-huh we could resign or we could allow
we could allow a checkmate uh in great
style
uh but yeah i mean
we are not far from getting checkmated
here
for example if rook captures bishop f6
we are
very very low on squares
very unpleasant bishop b5 checks
something like king f7 rook can come
here
[Music]
yeah it's not going to be not going to
be pleasant
yeah i don't know you guys you guys
decide do we do we play this out to to
get checkmated or do do you guys want to
see resigns
wow so many so many different opinions
it's looking pretty bad yeah
it's looking pretty bad
you did a ted talk saying it's always
fun to give checkmate
so we should allow the checkmate okay
so
what's the what's the fastest way we
allow this okay so now
for those of you who are just joining in
we've sacrificed the pawn so unit is not
only up a pawn but she has the bishop
pair she has a nicely placed rook on the
e-file and we are somewhat
underdeveloped with both of our pawns
hanging here
so not not a great day for us
uh
but yeah
wha what do you guys decided
resigns or
find find the quickest way to checkmate
okay i'm seeing some mixed messages here
but i think resigns is the way to go
yeah
as so many people voting cannot be wrong
so i i say we we gracefully resign this
yeah
it's settled
all right guys good game
we resigned this
i think uh i i agree with the decision i
mean it would be very over in a few
moves uh completely over so
uh it was the it was the
the way to go
i don't like sicilian we should have
played e5 yeah
it was uh it was a good game yeah we're
gonna we're gonna analyze it uh
i still have to make uh
at least uh a few videos uh regarding
the will the charity cup that is
currently being played but this will i
think i will make a video on this game
probably if not today
tomorrow morning but let me just check
what is happening in the
in the stream now
we haven't had a look in this one for a
while and anna's community wow my first
thought on this is that so why did
all right so let's check the let's check
the world board
right for those of you who are
interested
uh we can check out what actually
happened here
let's pull out this analysis board and
see how how impressive our sacrifice was
so
all right so this is all standard e5 was
played knight b5 d6 c4
uh f5 okay the engine is not crazy about
it but uh
uh
it's it's something i wouldn't stress
about uh he captures and now bishop
captures an f5 obviously uh should be
played we played knight here and this
allows you to defend the pawn you can
see that uh the engine gives our uh
move a question mark but also an
exclamation mark so it's not just a
question mark we have to be proud of
that
uh bishop to d3 you defended it and now
we kick away the knight knight goes back
we play bishop to e7 and unit uh defends
the pawn with g4
so very very very very aggressive
uh we played h6 here and now you just
played bishop to e3 and now
we went for this aggressive d5 move and
while the engine says our d5 move is
incredibly strong or rather the
strongest move in the position
uh we are
not uh in a great position even though
we kind of felt that we are uh but seems
that unit completely uh completely
outplayed us and and uh
well
uh the the f5 move if played has to be
recaptured this knight to f6 is simply
too ambitious for her
uh for someone of ut's caliber uh so
after captures we played captures here
and this is now just dead lost uh
someone was suggesting f6 here from the
from the chat and uh well no one
considered this really
it does seem to be completely winning
for unit
uh what f6 and then
our bishop is attacked
okay and after bishop captures on b4
there's bishop to g6 yeah that's very
very
very unpleasant
uh yeah and then the knight hangs okay
that's really really good so we've
missed that but luckily uh
she did as well she played knight
captures here we played queen captures
and that's why our position seemingly
uh got pleasant uh
uh all of a sudden the this queen
captures on d5 was was uh
some a second chance that we got that
maybe we shouldn't have
uh we we were attacking the rook and now
uh she just castled here and now knight
to b4
uh and interestingly the engine gives
this as a zero zero so we've completely
equalized now
after white misses this f6 idea and now
after she played bishop back to e2 we
have to trade queens that's the way to
go but we played bishop to d7
and obviously this is simply not enough
knight to c3 is now too strong yeah we
had to exploit this uh rook uh still
being uh blocked by the knight uh and
that would force whites to put uh her
pieces awkwardly because you will have
to recapture the queen with the bishop
now after knight c3 captures captures
our position is bad uh bishop to c6
which seemed like a good idea now rook
d2 yeah it's the winning move it's the
one that you displace now this is the
threat uh yeah not not not fun a6
making room for our knight just a three
night a six now night here and here we
after rook to e8 uh she doubled up on
the e file we traded everything here and
resigned the game so really really
impressive stuff
uh
but yeah
this is why uh it seemed like it
shouldn't be possible
uh but uh yeah and it wasn't f6 here
after night captures is just uh crushing
uh so yeah that was uh
super fun
yeah but you can see how how how strong
uh eureka uh
uh yuri is and how how well she
basically just crushed us uh
without without breaking a sweat
and she's playing against 10 other
people as well
plus the world board
okay i will just join the zoom call very
quickly
i thought this is going to be the
perfect moment to jump in on it you
should see the faces of our camera guys
they are loving the show as well i mean
i cannot prove it to you but they
definitely do all right so
we are uh uh technically
look at this i've got i just pulled up
chat and ankushrama is saying
is going to make a comeback
okay is he gonna make a comeback on this
game let's get an update with what is
the position last we left it it looked
like things were a bit out of hand i'm
not sure did we have some moves after
knight g5 chat maybe you can tell us
what is the move that he actually chose
abhishek with the update that he's
actually getting he's very close to
being mated i'm sorry i just want to
jump on this hype by going we need more
squids all right chet we are going to
come back from five and we need you to
put out those tentacles and make it the
biggest
most complex emoji wave the north has
ever seen are you guys ready five
four
three two
one
let's see that let's see the wave come
on the tentacle away i wanna i wanna
witness it oh my god we're getting it
super awesome okay there's a lot of
squids and squids
that's that's definitely a nice wave
thank you thank you guys all right
where where were we we were trying to
see how much longer is this boat going
to survive let's bring this up uh and
after knight g5 what is the move that
was played because i'm again just not
getting an update on my board with queen
h5 threat queen d5 i
highly doubt that would be got antonio
with us so we'll come back to this one
let's see if he can hear us this time
antonio
do you copy good sir
i i feel hello there
he's really close of
okay i think he can hear us or we can't
see you he tries to communicate
oh maybe we have to just communicate too
because we can't hear him
that is by the way the youtube chess
channel of our god meter well i'm pretty
sure everyone already knows it i don't
think there's a single chassis
enthusiast who hasn't watched his videos
they're probably the best videos out
there to get into the game it's an
interesting compliment all right 100 i
think he's uh
he's sensational with his chess
educational uh videos super entertaining
super instructive compact and explains
the ideas really well with a lot of
captures captures capture captures
and uh despite all the positive things
we can say about him right now it is not
the time for us to
we have
the miracle of sound can you hear us
uh yes yes
we've got a few moves so c3 happen here
short castle and d4 antonio what would
be your picture with black
oh this is all uh this is all still very
very sorry this is all still a very very
heavy theory as i imagine as the votes
are are coming in
uh but what was played the white played
d4 uh well we we
[Music]
yeah we we we capture we we d captures
on d4
is against choice here you know what
let's go with that one
i think this is the one that the world
has chosen actually we have gone for e
takes d4 and now we're expecting her to
recapture with the pawn and if this
happens antonio do you just fall back
with the bishop to b6 now
um i i think i've like analyzed this
position so many times that it's uh i
guess it's sort of still theory if the
the bishop can come to both b6 and a7
for some reason so i i guess people will
choose b6
i would go for bishop b6 here as well so
this one's heating up
but
we'll come back to this uh just really
quickly going back to your board yes
after this you've got a chance to come
back to the game and then eventually do
that manage to win it tell us about the
experience of playing against judith and
for your community to have the
opportunity of this game
yeah i think we we we got the absolute
best experience possible
uh we got to play a very sharp line
against unit or rather okay there are
some sharper sicilians but we
we kind of made it super sharp with that
f5 move which allowed her to to you know
go for the
full attack with the g4
and uh well we we we are not
disappointed uh we we tried we he
uh we saw what she can do and she is uh
still incredible as as she ever was so i
i i find it better
for you and we would like to play it now
that's a that's gg from the woman
herself
antonia you've made such a amazing
videos and uh
where you're analyzing all these great
games that have been played a lot of
them are of judith's games as well that
you've looked up and then you've
produced videos on her style of play of
course we all know has always been
aggressive and
do you think after analyzing her game so
intensively that she will probably be
the master of attacking chess for
generations to come
well uh most definitely i think uh
uh if you if you allow her a position
where attacking is possible then
no one is safe and uh whoever faced her
has experienced that without without
exceptions i think
uh and uh that that will not change i
think it will take quite some time for
for someone to to even come close
i completely agree and finally before we
let you go are we going to see an agave
video on the game that just happened yes
yes of course i will try to make it
today but if if not then tomorrow for
sure
congratulations and really just the
biggest round of applause to you and
your entire community
thank you so much antonio we really hope
that
we'll see all of you from antonio's
community on our world board as well
thank you all right until next time
cheers
[Music]
all right so there you have it you've uh
you've seen it you've heard it uh we've
uh we've played a nice game uh but it
simply wasn't our day
uh so sorry about tuning out for for
that brief interview but i didn't know
if it'd be better if i left the audio on
or left the audio off
it's just uh
never actually uh
attempted something like this so i
didn't know the
most proper way to include it in the
live stream
uh but yeah maybe
maybe
leaving the audio on would have been a
little bit better
uh so uh like i said i don't know for
how long will i be keeping the stream on
because we've already been going for
like four hours or yeah okay close to
even five hours yeah
uh but yeah uh join join them and join
the eurotpolga versus the world.hungary
expo 2020
and you can finish off the game you did
polgar versus the world i imagine it
will be uh incredibly incredibly
impressive as it's still all very very
heavy theory and dude will have her
hands full on on this game so uh we're
definitely going to analyze our game uh
for the uh for the channel as soon as i
get the opportunity and then we're gonna
analyze uh probably this game as well
that she's playing against the world and
if you guys have any
uh if you guys have any games that you
would like to enjoy uh from the other
players as well uh then
uh
then uh
do use hashtag suggestion and i will try
to uh implement that as well
so i might be returning with the stream
uh but uh for the moment that's it for
for the stream thank you all for joining
and thank you all for
uh helping us fight unit in this
incredible game for those of you who
still haven't seen it i will just go
through it one more time very quickly so
uh e4c5 we played the sicilian defense
and after accepting the open sicilian we
went for this e5 very strong svechnikov
line
the pelican the last card there are many
names to it uh knight to b5 d6 and now
c4 we went for the extremely aggressive
f5 uh which is good for blitz probably
not good for a correspondence game but
we wanted to see if it can be played
captures and now knight to f6
so
a lot of you suggested we should capture
back right away but this seemed a lot
more interesting and after you did
defended the pawn we played h3 kicked
away the knight knight goes back bishop
to e7 and now we are ready to castle and
then maybe some ideas can be thrown
around but yo it goes for the extremely
aggressive g4
uh and now we played h6 there were some
discussions about maybe h5 maybe who
knows what maybe we counter but uh
this uh kind of seemed like a good idea
because uh
well she also has to decide what to do
with her own king and now after bishop
to e3 we just play d5 which again is the
strongest move recommended by the engine
uh it's just that our position is not
all that dreamy so captures captures and
now uh comes our lucky break and that is
knight captures on d5 but you did had
this beautiful beautiful f6 move which
completely shatters our defenses but
we're gonna analyze this more deeply in
the actual game here she allowed us back
into the game but now after castles uh
we played knights to b4 again absolute
strongest and after bishop e2
now we started uh
to really misplay this because uh well
okay you should you should trade while
the while the rook is still slumbering
on his starting square but we actually
developed the bishop as we wanted to
assume this diagonal before white beats
us to it and then after
uh white attacks the queen we traded
queens played bishop to c6 but now you
can see that there's a problem with this
a3 move
and urid of course does not allow us to
bring the knight to c2 so she brings the
rook here now a3 is a huge threat and
now after
h5 which kind of gives us an escape
square for the knight uh h
a3 knight goes back and now knight d5
it's just a terrible terrible position
for black
we played rook d8 and after she doubles
up on the d file now just captures
captures captures captures and he was in
this position on move 23 that we decided
to resign the game uh so it's a fully
justified resignation the position is
terrible for black and uh well we could
have
dragged the game on for a few more moves
but
it
seemed like this is uh
uh like uh it was the most appropriate
thing to do
uh so yeah i'm gupta i think for the
contribution to the channel and also
john doe thanks a lot for the
contribution uh yeah 23 moves we are
partners but you defeated uh some very
strong world-renowned grandmasters in 23
moves so we shouldn't be all that sad
okay so expect a full analysis on this
game uh that's it for for the stream uh
uh well see you guys see you guys soon